Keck wait 10 Uhr sonntags beten wir eine runde er hat zu dir keinen zwang an
wenn du eine runde beten willst dann bete es gibt ja leider kein beten emote mehr
ich glaube bless rng wurde nie ich hätte nur den zu binden bless rng wurde ja gebannt ist ja weg
er gut emojis gibt es ja aber warum wurde der bless rng typ noch mal gebannt ganz vergessen
keine ahnung und so lange her hat er nicht seine freundin geschlagen oder so was haben sie ihn
gebannt und nee nee nee nee warte mal das war in den andern keine ahnung ich weiß nicht mal ich
weiß nicht mal warum warum da blickst du nicht mehr durch könnt ihr euch noch an den an diesen
ein fortnite streamer erinnern den sie gebannt haben uns und stream weil er weiß ich so angehört
als hätte seine freundin geschlagen meine güte da ging es echt hoch her das war echt komplette
eskalation dieses dieses video erst kommen seine freundin rein schmeißt irgendwie sein monitor und
sein rechner fast runter und dann rennt heraus und klatscht ja eine das wie kann man so bescheuert
sein so was auch noch on stream also ich will es generell nicht gut heißen aber wie kann man
bescheuert ist auch noch on stream alles so eskalieren zulassen egal egal alles hatte bis
voll sich mit näher beschäftigen sein stream benachrichtigen kam nicht an
bei wahrscheinlich weil der bot so langsam war vielleicht braucht er bot noch ein bisschen ja
youtube hat leider nicht allzu viel hergegeben was videos angeht aber ein paar habe ich es gibt mal
wieder ein neues battle field 3 top play video hat jetzt irgendwie fünf monate gedauert bis
man eins hat na gut spielt ja auch kaum einer ja level cap jibane damit fangen wir an
level cap jibane damit fangen wir an weil ich muss mal kurz was trinken habe ich mal
t hingestellt lull eben acht da muss das er eben noch neben mir stand der tner jetzt habe
ich ihn irgendwie hinten auf ein basteltisch da geballt gestellt keine ahnung warum auf einmal
habt ihr das auch schon mal gehabt dass ihr sachen einfach nicht seht die da sind also jetzt nicht auf
den t-bezug ich habe das mal mit meinem mikrofon gehabt das mikrofon stand monatelang auf dem
gleich auf der gleichen stelle am schreibtisch und eines tages habe ich gedacht okay ich bräuchte
jetzt mal das mikrofon wollte das anschließen habe es nicht gefunden ich habe es nicht gefunden ich
habe es nicht gesehen weil es so quasi schon übergegangen ist in meinem hirn in den schreibtisch
weil es immer an der gleichen stelle stand ich habe das nicht gesehen das mikro ja genau hier
richtig richtig wo bault und irgendwann habe ich dann habe ich da ein paar tage später auf die
ecke geguckt wo es steht da ist mir klar geworden das mikrofon steht da schon die ganze zeit da
und ich hatte das jetzt schon paar mal wenn das mikrofon an dieser einen stelle hier steht da
wo es immer steht dann über sehe ich es einfach mal der scam train ist am stand für die subs
ihr könnt also übrigens alle subscriben weil es ist jetzt billiger geworden es kostet jetzt
bloß auf vier euro statt fünf euro ich kriege aber auch weniger ab im endeffekt unterm strich
bedeutet dass nur jeff muss mir 50 cent weniger überweist von prime subs also stripes 25 monat
hyper subscription hier massive der schäger ist am stand neue subpreise testen ja ja ich finde
auch also die neuen subpreise sollten noch mehr leute testen testet mal ob es wirklich nur vier
euro sind 18 monate hier leute no rules mein bedminister auch subscribes für die subs leute
was messen wapnick primes ab ist und gamble null benutzt arsch ja da hätte ich auch nicht
anders erwartet wir wissen ja dass die leute hier in dem stream außerordentlich high IQ sind was
sollte man sonst verwenden gentoo gentoo würde vielleicht noch durchgehen aber arch ist ja das
mindeste also ich erwarte jetzt also chat ich erwarte von euch schon dass ihr nicht mit so
08 15 distributionen um die ecke kommt hier also unter unter arch ist hier unter der würde des
chats außer auf einem surfer da lasse ich mir auch gefallen das ist tatsächlich ganz cool wenn
das das mit den containern ist das wollte ich schon immer mal ausprobieren einfach weil ich
konzept cool fand nicht zum nicht zum täglichen benutzen wobei wir uns ja einig sind wie ist das
jetzt mo bunthu ist da immer noch eindeutig das bett die beste distribution mit dem besten skin
mo bunthu nicht container ok dann akubo s mein ich ja kupo ist das habe ich gemeint dann habe
ich das ich habe ich mir nicht nix us sogar mal aufgeschrieben dass wir das ausprobieren
wollen also da warum ist standard suche notepad eigentlich ab ist tatsächlich nicht so als
wollte ich ausprobieren kuchen dienst moin sechs monate massive subscription was hältst du vom
windows war 2002 gibt es jetzt was neues echt jetzt was gibt es da review ok das was gibt
es neues neues zeigt mal her ich nicht dass mich windows und ich sehe es schon ich sehe ich sehe
schon dass das müssen ausprobieren und sei es nur dass ich mich darüber lustig machen kann und wir
eine runde windows keck keck wehen also wenn das wird darauf jetzt eh rauslaufen ich werde
wenn aus der runde auslachen im stream weil es wieder so merkwürdige dinge eingebaut hat aber
die natürlich nur für linux leute merkwürdig sind leute die nur windows verwenden für die
natürlich vollkommen normal das kommt uns zwei stunden windows an keck kecken uns eine runde
weg und dann ist gut vorbeugende verteidigung was ist das wieder für eine übersetzung wir
heißen dass wir heißt es im original advance protection prevent preventative defense ok das
tatsächlich ja also guck mal der verteidigt dich schon bevor du wusstest dass du verteidigt
werden musstest das ist quasi wie so eine wie so einen wie so ein turret an einem schiff gegen
raketen der schießt ja auch die rakete ab bevor dich die rakete hittet also bevor du so richtig
mitgekriegt hast dass die auf die schießen ist die rakete weg so was ist das anschein wie auch
immer das aussehen so ich sehe schon kommen das müssen wir ausprobieren system requiem
braucht man tpm geht das in der vm das schauen wir uns in einem der nächsten in einem der
nächsten streams an jetzt nicht jetzt nicht nicht schon wieder das müssen wir doch nicht
jeden stream machen hast du schon von der ausweispflicht ja ja habe ich gehört haben
wir uns sogar letzten stream angeguckt das video von von der wie heißen wie bs heißt
die bs soll merke meine ich aber heißt heißt der bs ach keine ahnung ja haben wir uns angeguckt
das video zu und es richtig bescheuert bs genau genau was du verpasst hast ja sie haben sich
jetzt überlegt alle alle webseiten brauchen jugend schutz freigabe und ansonsten ist die
webseite nicht aufrufbar was das internet quasi faktisch oder das internet wird dann wenn man
das ganze wirklich umsetzen würde zu einer white list also sprich du kannst nur noch
auf seiten zugreifen die freigegeben sind was leider schwachsinn ist ja übrigens ich
muss meinen ausweis verlängern lassen und ich habe gehört dass man jetzt ab august fingerabdrücke
abgeben muss für den ausweis die ganze zeit war das freiwillig ich glaube beim was jetzt los
ist das tross musik ach nee das ist ach das ist ok excellent die ganze zeit muss man das
glaube ich nur beim reise reisepass machen und jetzt muss man das auch für normalen ausweis
machen ich finde ich finde es naja ich kann es nachvollziehen aber ich habe trotzdem keinen
bock meiner fingerabdrücke abzugeben denkst du dass die grafikkartenpreise wieder runtergehen
na die sind ja schon runtergegangen guck mal wenn es hier vergleicht wobei ich glaube das ist ja
nur das ist ja nur das teuerste am tag die grafikkarten grafikkartenpreise sind ein bisschen
runtergegangen aber nachdem ich immer das höchste am tag nehme ist das natürlich ein durchschnitt
am tag nehmen ist es nicht so also ein bisschen runtergegangen ist es aber nachdem wir ziemlich
akuten halbleiter grams mangel haben wird das alles betreffen und ich glaube nicht dass
die grafikkarten in nächster zeit wieder richtig günstig werden
ich denke das beste was man machen kann ist aktuell wenn man noch mit seinem rechner auskommt
man sollte jetzt nicht übers kniebrechen was neues zu kaufen aber wenn man es handhabt
wie immer quasi der rechner ist paintchampi langsam oder man kann mit seiner seinem rechner
mit seiner aktuellen hardware nicht das machen was man will dann kauft man sich halt was
neues ich brauche etwas entspannteres ja besser f-sharp f-sharp ist pock auch wenn ich nicht
verwende weil ich keine ahnung habe davon ja schon gar nicht die china chinesen weiß
gar nicht ob die offiziell überhaupt so was haben
es sind keine bilder von fünge abdrücken im perso oder soweit ich weiß ist es so da
ist du musst deine finger abdrücke einscannen und die werden dann verschlüsselt angeblich
auf dem chip im personalausweis also das sind keine finger abdrücke auf dem personalausweis
drauf glaube ich zumindest und sie sagen natürlich das ist super sicher und das kann niemand
auslesen außer offizielle behörden und bla bla bla bla ich meine wir kennen sie im endeffekt
man muss sich einfach nur mal die wahnsinnigen erfolge in der letzten jahre der IT projekte
in deutschland angucken dann weiß man eigentlich schon bescheid dass das alles gelaber ist
zum beispiel elektronische gesundheitskarte und so was hat ja alles wahnsinnig gut funktioniert
und sehr gut durchdacht oder ein private key für alle apotheken in deutschland zum korona
stels ausstellen und so was ja wir sollten genau wir sollten nach führend sein in digitalen
behördengängen bis 2021 und so was alles gelaber also kannst du im prinzip nichts drauf
geben deswegen ist die einfachste variante solange man nicht gesetzlich dazu verpflichtet
ist irgendwo mitzumachen da kannst du dich ja im endeffekt nicht gegenwehren außer vielleicht
auswandern aber selbst dann brauchst du das mindestens per so das beste ist wenn du nicht
dazu gesetzlich verpflichtet bist was zu machen möglichst sparsam mit deinem zeug umgehen
was nicht irgendwo in der cloud ist hat auch keine probleme später mal und was nicht nur
über irgendwelche hersteller services funktioniert kann auch nicht kaputt gehen ich erinnere
noch mal an die leute die vor glaube ich könnte schon fast wieder ein jahr her sein wo es
letztens letzten winter in den usa sind irgendwelche amazon services ausgefallen ja doch amazon
amazon services aufgefallen und thermostate die amazon cloud verwendet haben ging nicht
mehr also sprich die leute konnten ihre heizung nicht mehr bedienen weil es über die cloud
ging da muss ich auch mal kurz kecken eine runde und hat mir gedacht wer macht so einen
scheiß freiwillig ja gestern am thermostat frisst ihr den arsch ab und es geht nicht
weil die cloud ausgefallen ist fingerabdruck im ausweis ist ab 1 august pflicht das erste
ist schon verweigert ja seit 1 august personal august 2021 schon mit fingerabdruck ja das
ist jetzt und ich muss ende des jahres verlängern lassen ausweispflicht auf os eben wie soll
das funktionieren so wie die sich das vorstellen wahrscheinlich gar nicht das ist wieder was
was sich leute ausgedacht haben da war wahrscheinlich wieder irgendwelche lobby menschen am start
ein bisschen lobbyiert das ist technisch kaum umsetzbar und und auch wie soll man sagen
verwaltungstechnisch schwer umsetzbar es sagen ja sogar die gar also es sagen alle
IT verbände sie haben kein bock auf den scheiß und es sagen sogar die stellen die sowas kontrollieren
müssen also wen haben wir da fsk und was nicht alles gibt die sagen ja auch ist schwachsinn
also es ist total es ist total bescheuert ja gut man kann man kann das ja schon seit
ein paar jahren machen also ich sehe da jetzt auch nicht so das allzu große problem drin
ich finde es aber bedenklich dass an vielen stellen erstmal die sachen erhoben werden
und quasi ab dem stichtag das geschrei dann groß ist und nach dem motto das ist doch
so unsicher ich meine man hätte ja eine zeit so man hätte ja zeit gehabt dass ihm vorfällt
bedenken aus dem weg zu schaffen aber und wie gesagt man hat es an private keys für
alle apotheken gesehen dass da nicht unbedingt die allergrößten fife hats am start sind
die das design und was man auch gesehen hat warte mal kurz ja und was man auch gesehen
hat dass regelungen immer gerne aufgeweicht werden zum beispiel hat man ja am anfang gesagt
wenn die diese zettel die man ausfüllen muss im restaurant wann man da war also wegen wegen
corona dass man infektionsketten nachvollziehen kann hat man am anfang gesagt also in bayern
weiß ich dass man da schon wieder von abgerückt ist man hat gesagt das wird rein zum nachverfolgen
von benutzt von infektionsketten und irgendwie ein paar wochen später kam dann die bayerische
polizei und hat gemeint ja aber wir hätten da auch gerne zugriff drauf hat man so ja
ok obwohl man vorher explizit gesagt hat nein das wird nur für diesen einen zweck verwendet
also das heißt man kann eh nicht davon ausgehen dass das was man heute hört und dem man heute
quasi zustimmen dass das wenn man es nicht ganz genau verfolgt dass es in einem halben
jahr oder jahr immer noch so ist das ist auch so ein bisschen problematisch dass viele sachen
immer durch die hintertür gemacht werden dass die leute nicht mitkriegen das ja auch absicht
werder aufschrei bei vielen sachen immer viel größer so übrigens diese meinen trossel
geschichte habe ich gelesen kann man teilweise schon umgehen bei grafikkarten wieder hast
du mitbekommen dass man jetzt wieder ads blocken kann auf twitch nee gibt es wahrscheinlich
extra addons oder so aber natürlich will ich nicht dass ihr ads blockt weil kriegst
ja kein geld weniger ich selbst blocken natürlich weiterhin alle ads ist auch so es ist auch
so guck dir den internetausbau an wobei es ja nicht nur internetausbau ist ja wenn ich
mir so sachen angucke wie infrastruktur gerade was was bahn angeht ist halt auch schon hart
lächerlich wenn man sich anguckt dass die letzten jahre über teilweise strecken stillgelegt
wurden und weichen abgebaut wurden die man jetzt wieder braucht das ist einfach falsche
zielsetzung du kannst nicht sagen wir wollen also du kannst du kannst nicht beides haben
du kannst nicht sagen wir möchten möglichst gute verfügbarkeit und infrastruktur die halt
auch geld kostet gleichzeitig verbinden mit wir möchten das börsen fit machen und möglichst
viel gewinnen das sind halt zwei sachen die sich oftmals beißen das heißt man muss erst
mal die richtige zielsetzung haben also was möchte man möchte man einfach nur möglichst
viel geld rauspressen und es ist einem egal ob das irgendwie gute versorgung für die
für die bevölkerung ist oder will man sagen die versorgung für die bevölkerung ist uns
wichtig also scheißen wir auch ein bisschen auf geld ich sage nicht dass die bahn nur
miese machen soll aber muss ich halt angucken wie der fokus darauf liegt so und die letzten
jahre war es eindeutig so wir wollen die bahn also zumindest wollte man dass man ursprünglich
die bahn an die börse bringt und hat dann dementsprechend ohne rücksicht auf verluste
sachen eingespart strecken stillgelegt abgebaut personal abgebaut und in der hoffnung dass
man das erst quasi paar jahre später merkt wenn die sache in trockenen tücher ist und
ja man merkt es jetzt ein paar jahre später guten trockenen tücher ist immer noch nix
aber man merkt es jetzt ein paar jahre später dass es eben nicht gut war für verfügbarkeit
und versorgung und jetzt ist man wild hinterher da wieder aufzurüsten und kommt nicht hinterher
hätte man sich halt vielleicht mal langfristig andere ziele setzen sollen das problem ist
auch wenn alle apotheken die die den gleichen key haben ist du kannst ja nichts zurückrufen
deswegen ist es ja auch so normalerweise dass du für alles einen eigenen key hast oder dass
es sowas wie revoke-listen gibt beispielsweise bei zertifikaten dass du eben auch sachen
wieder zurückrufen kannst vorher war es freiwillig richtig richtig
vorher war das freiwillig mit fingerabdrücken abgeben jetzt ist das pflicht seit 1 august
genau das ist auch so ein punkt der oft vergessen wird selbst wenn was jetzt als sicher gilt
und man die sachen irgendwo in eine cloud legt die daten sind ja potenziell dann für
immer dort ob das dann wirklich so ist kommt drauf an was damit passiert aber potenziell
sind die daten wenn du sie einmal ins internet geschoben hast immer im internet und selbst
wenn du das jetzt sagen wir mal sicher verschlüsselt hast oder wenn du das jetzt nach aktuellen
maßstäben gesichert hast heißt es nicht dass es in zehn jahren immer noch der fall ist
es gab verschlüsselungsmechanismen oder auch auch hash-algorithmen sagen wir mal md5 zum
beispiel die vor zehn jahren als sicher galten und jetzt nicht mehr oder es gab bestes beispiel
ist wahrscheinlich wep bei wladen das galte auch mal als sicher heute wie lang dauert
heute wep zu knacken zwei minuten 25 keine ahnung es geht saumäßig schnell
das habe ich gesehen da habe ich sogar ein video zu oft gemacht mal gucken was er dazu
sagt so ja das machen sie aber nicht das problem bei der bahn ist aus meiner sicht
nicht irgendwie die leute oder sonst also nicht nicht die mitarbeiter oder sonst was
also den kann ich da also ich rede von den normalen mitarbeiter nicht von management
stels den kann ich da eigentlich gar keinen vorwurf machen ich glaube da leisten viele
tagtäglich mehr als die vertraglich müssten einfach dass das scheiß funktioniert leider
ist es das ist das sieht man in der pflege auch ganz gut dass es mittlerweile schon als
normalzustand angenommen wird dass die leute sich kaputt machen und sich überarbeiten
dass man quasi sagt ja gut dann können wir fünf leute weniger einstellen weil die anderen
15 die wir haben 15 die wir haben arbeiten ja schon für 20 da brauchen ja keine 20 das
ist halt big brain das stonks logik das kommt halt raus wenn zu viele bvl leute bei sowas
mit am start sind ja und solang es bei der bahn keine konsequenzen gibt und es reicht
die statistik die die statistik sich schön zu rechnen oder eben haltestellen ausfallen
zu lassen um zu sagen der zug ist pünktlich solange das reicht und das keine konsequenzen
hatte du willst ja auch nichts tun warum auch die bahn ist also ganz im ernst wenn du wirklich
pünktlich von a nach b willst wenn wirklich wo es drauf ankommt also wenn es wirklich
drauf ankommt da kann ich niemand ruhigen gewissen sagen fahrt mit der bahn ich fahre
selbst mit der bahn fast ausschließlich wenn ich nach frankfurt fahre aber wenn ich wirklich
irgendwo hin müsste dann würde ich da würde ich mit dem auto fahren ja deswegen ist schwierig
glaube nicht dass das passieren wird deswegen ist es ja auch geradezu wie nennt man das
lächerlich ist das falsche wort irgendwie kontraproduktiv ja wenn man wenn man jetzt
so ideen in den raum wirft wie man sollte verbieten mit dem auto in die stadt zu fahren
und so was wie soll das dann funktionieren die bahn ist im arsch dass so wenn die das
jetzt in dem tempo weitermachen wie sie es die letzten jahre über verbessert hat dann
wird es auch noch ein bisschen dauern bitte zeitlang so sein dass die im arsch sind und
wie passt es damit zusammen ohne alternativen den leuten zu sagen ihr dürft mit dem auto
nicht mehr in die stadt fahren das leuchten wir überhaupt nicht ein ich bin es prinzipiell
gut dass man nicht mehr mit dem auto in die stadt fährt gar keine frage allein schon
weil die luft in der stadt viel besser wird aber die bahn ist ja wohl eines der wichtigsten
sachen dafür dass die leute nicht mehr mit dem auto die stadt in die stadt fahren müssen
und wenn die bahn pünktlich oder sagen wir mal zumindest zuverlässig wäre wenn sie
oft genug fährt oder im endeffekt pünktlich von dich von a nach b bringt dann sagen sicherlich
viele leute ne dann fahre ich nicht mit dem auto weil spaß machen mit dem auto nach frankfurt
zu fahren weiß ich gibt bestimmt leute sind hardcore autofahrer die wollen nie was anderes
machen aber ich finde es jetzt nicht so geil und wenn das ganze noch zuverlässiger wäre
dann sagen sicherlich viele ja nö brauche nicht mehr ja und so lange das so lange das
nicht ist ist das alles nur rum gedockt da an an irgendwelchen symptomen ohne dass man
an der eigentlichen problematik was ändert zumal man ja auch sagen muss elektroautos
da wurde ich da wurde ich ja geflammt vor ein paar vor ein paar jahren in den videos
weiß noch ich habe ich habe vor ein paar jahren als als es noch nicht so absehbar war
dass bei uns auch elektroautos ist quasi die zukunft sind habe ich mal gesagt ich bin
skeptisch ab wann das mal die zukunft sein wird aber es zeichnet sich jetzt ja ab wobei
man halt sagen muss aktuell sind elektroautos ja noch nicht irgendwie jetzt der der bringer
was was umweltschutz angeht das wird es aber in zukunft sicherlich werden also wenn
man sich man muss ja aktuell angucken wie wird das strom hergestellt mit dem ich das
ding lade und was brauche ich um so elektroauto zu bauen also sonderlich umweltfreundlich
ist elektroauto aktuell auch noch nicht aber das wird hoffentlich in zukunft werden deswegen
ist es auch gerade wichtig das ist ja eines der sachen die wir glücklicherweise nicht
verpennt haben damit zu machen aber die mussten ja auch den blieb ja auch gar nichts anderes
übrig die haben die normalen autos ja nicht mal verkauft bekommen die werden gut immer
noch auch die nächsten paar jahre über normale autos mit verbrennermotor verkaufen aber garantiert
nicht mehr in zukunft die stückzahlen mit denen sie aktuell viel kohle machen also die
mussten ja und was man daran auch schön sieht finde ich ist wenn der druck da ist dass was
gemacht werden muss weil man sonst morgen nicht mehr da ist dann klappt das auch ganz gut da
geht das da geht das zackig ja so huppst ja wenn wir da nicht mitmachen sind wir in fünf
jahren wahrscheinlich nicht mehr da ja gut dann machen wir halt mit also kann funktionieren
das wusste ich nicht würde mich würde mich wundern aber kann sein ja gut aber hat ja
eigentlich keine ausweckung da drauf dass du die leute pünktlich von a nach b bringen
solltest gibt's ja gibt's ja schon genug ich war ich war nie auf einer privaten schule
leute ich habe keine ahnung aber ich könnte mir vorstellen dass je nach finanzierungsmodell
der schule die lehrer besser sind die ausbildung dementsprechend besser ist die ausstattung
besser ist und die klassengrößen kleiner sind kostet aber auch dementsprechend geld
ich habe keine ahnung ich war noch nie auf einer privaten schule aber ich könnte mir
vorstellen dass dort keine fernsehwagen mit crt und video recorder mehr rumgeschoben
werden was glaubst du wie es mit dem glasfaserausbau weitergeht langsam wenn du jetzt teilweise
meldung liest wo die leute kein glasfaser bekommen weil vor einem jahr oder so dort
erst noch kupferdinger ausgebaut wurden und das dann quasi keine fördergelder mehr gibt
oder irgendwelche komischen konstrukte die wir da wieder haben
IT heutzutage funktioniert leider nur über unbezahlte überstunden das sehe ich in der
IT sehe ich tatsächlich ein bisschen anders weil die haben krasse probleme halt leute
zu bekommen dementsprechend bist du da noch ein bisschen
am längeren himmel also ich mache keinerlei bezahlte unbezahlte überstunden ich könnte
mir aber vorstellen dass das aber in so kleineren turnschuhadmin leden vielleicht eher der fall
ist aber trotzdem was sollen sie machen wenn du sagst mache ich nicht könnte ich rausschmeißen
und dann finden sie keinen
kann man auch man gibt verschiedene möglichkeiten aber uns wird sich halt anbieten mal die bahn
auf vordermann zu bringen dass man eben nicht drauf angewiesen ist wenn man pünktlich da
sein will dass man mit dem auto fährt das dumme ist ja auch wenn du mit dem auto fährst
fährst ja auch alleine meistens zu irgendwelchen terminen und eventuell auch mit einem richtig
fetten auto alleine das ist ja so eins der umweltschädlichsten sachen die du machen
kannst verkehrstechnisch es gibt sicherlich viele varianten aber bei uns wird sich auf
jeden fall anbieten die bahn mal auf vordermann zu bringen
doch schulungen sollten immer arbeitzeit sein also wenn du dich privat wenn du dich privat
weiter bildest dann natürlich nicht aber wenn dein arbeitgeber sagt du musst die schulung
xy besuchen was weiß ich dann arbeitgeber will dass so eine eitel schulung macht selbstverständlich
ist die dann arbeitszeit bei extern kann man sich darüber streiten also bei uns wird
das meistens so gehandhabt für interne ist ganz klar schulung ist bezahlt und schulung
ist arbeitszeit für externe ist es meistens so da können sie denen ja die teilnahme nicht
vorschreiben dann sagen sie ok es ist keine arbeitszeit aber wir bezahlen die schulung
was ich auch nur eigentlich für externe ganz faires angebot finde man könnte man hätte
ja auch sagen können schulung ist voraussetzung ansonsten können wir euch nicht weiter beschäftigen
was aber aktuell schwierig ist weil die brauchen ja leute es ist das ist eh witzig solange
die handeligen leute suchen umso mehr bereit sind natürlich auch alle arbeitgeber den jeweiligen
experten entgegenzukommen ist ja logisch sieht man ja auch also viele viele unternehmen sind
ja mittlerweile richtig ja also man könnte sagen die hatten ja die erleuchtung über
nacht dass es darauf ankommt dass die leute zufrieden sind beziehungsweise dass man ihnen
ein paar vorteile bietet die sie eben ans ans unternehmen bindet und das aber vorteile
bietet die sie sonst nicht sonst nicht bekommen ja zum beispiel ein punkt den ich richtig
cool finde auch wenn es mich nicht betrifft aber ich denke mir wenn es mich betreffen
betreffen würde ist zum beispiel in kindergarten in der nähe beziehungsweise kinderbetreuung
das ist eigentlich eines der besten argumenten was du jemand liefern kannst dort anzufangen
selbst wenn du ein bisschen weniger geld bekommst wenn du nicht erst zum kindergarten musst
dann zurück dann zur arbeit und dann auf dem dann dich darum kümmern dass die kinder keine
ahnung mittags irgendwie noch zur oma opa gebracht werden und sonst wie dass du einfach
viel mehr stunden zeit am tag und viel weniger probleme also kinderbetreuung an der arbeit
glaube ich eines der größten plus punkte die man bieten kann für leute mit kinder
also ebay klein anzeigen würde ich garantiert keine 800 euro grafikkarte kaufen auf ehrenbruder
basis war das letzte preis in der schweiz haben wir das gleiche problem der öffentliche
nachverkehr ist oft nicht zuverlässig erreicht an wochen oft keine oft keine kleine gemeint
ist auch ihr also wenn schon was für schweizerverhältnisse zu teuer ist dann ist ja ja das
sind auch so sachen die beißen sich einfach die beißen sich sowas ist in der aktuellen
zeit eigentlich wichtiger denn je aber wie kannst du es den leuten die einfach ihr normales
leben bestreiten müssen übel nehmen dann dagegen zu sein das ist das ist das ist so
ein das ist so ein konflikt wo ich sage du musst eigentlich mal so diese ganzen widersprüche
und konflikte aus der welt schaffen dass du das überhaupt überhaupt machen kannst also
ich bin mal gefahren also nach ich war ich war glaube nur einmal in münchen bisher da
bin ich gefahren frankfurt münchen und das ging eigentlich ganz gut oder sogar hanau
münchen glaube ich das ging das ging eigentlich ganz gut hat ein bisschen gedauert münchen
der hauptbahnhof hat mich ein bisschen an frankfurt erinnert nur kleiner weil es auch ein sack
hauptbahnhof ist oder ich bringe es jetzt total durcheinander aber münchen hauptbahnhof
ist es ist es ist ein sack ein kopf wie heißt man es ein kopfbahnhof oder so ne von den
kleisen rechts ist der mcdonalds das weiß ich noch so sachen merkt man sich immer warum
auch immer es geht rechts rum rechts rum bin ich zumindest rausgegangen von den kleisen
ja naja gut wie auch immer ich auch nicht ich habe aktuell glaube ich minus fünf stunden
auf meinem konto übrigens ich weiß nicht was ein renault wie sie ist wahrscheinlich
irgendwie kleines elektroroller ah ne ah so ein ding ok ach sind das nicht die wo sie
letzten gesagt haben dürfen nicht auf dem bürgerstark parken jetzt ist es das photoshop oder sitzt
er da wirklich drin das photoshop das gesicht von dem dude ist das photoshopped oder sitzt
er da echt drin ich keine ahnung es sieht es sieht schon krass photoshopped aus aber
es könnte auch einfach dort von der aufnahme her sein aber es sieht es sieht schon ein
bisschen photoshopped aus oder es sieht ein bisschen photoshopped aus ich glaube der
typische echt wahrscheinlich nicht leute ich habe tatsächlich gestern mal kurzzeitig
überlegt wie es mit elektroauto aussieht weil ihr kennt ja mein auto das wird auch
nicht jünger und ich habe denken das macht sich mal lang da habe ich mir gedacht ok
es gibt jetzt ja prämien irgendwelche elektroauto prämien ich habe mir jetzt überlegt entweder
kaufe ich mir etwas kleines reicht für mich voll und ganz aus also ich kaufe mir garantiert
ich kaufe mir garantiert kein fette tesla oder mercedes oder bmw oder irgendwas irgendwas
kleines so und ich bin mir auch nicht sicher ob ich das lesen soll oder ob ich es kaufe
mit der prämie keine ahnung aber wahrscheinlich überlege ich das jetzt und lasse es bleiben
und warte bis mein auto komplett im arsch ist ja sehe ich genauso ja ist so es ist man
kann sich ja auch nur an neuen konzepten ausprobieren wie irgendwelche shuttle services oder sonst
was ja vollkommen ok aber man sollte nicht den zweiten schritt vor dem ersten machen
nicht den leuten verbieten ihr auto zu benutzen wenn es keine alternativen gibt die beste
alternative gegen auto ist immer noch also die das eigentlich der dritte schritt aber
hat man jetzt in corona gesehen dass der bringt einfach so viel wie möglich home office überall
möglichkeiten bieten ja das doch ok das finde ich nicht schlecht
es soll vorkommen es soll vorkommen habe ich gehört ich kann jetzt nicht aus persönlicher
erfahrung sprechen das wisst ihr aber es soll vorkommen
jeder fernverkehr ist pünktlich weil die so dinge machen wie wir lassen den halt ausfallen
und solche dinge also die statistik bei der bahn ist extrem schön gerechnet wir lassen
haltestellen ausfallen und dann war er an der stelle pünktlich oder erst pünktlich
weil das ein neuer enthalt ist oder wir rechnen wenn man umsteigen muss und den anschluss verpasst
aber der anschluss pünktlich ist ist dann auch die fahrt pünktlich und so komische
dinge also es und und ab wann überhaupt verspätung gilt es ist es ist schon extrem heftig schön
gerechnet die bahn statistik und sogar da ist sie oftmals schlechter also trotz schön
gerecht ist es eigentlich so gut wie immer schlechter als das was die bahn immer so als
ziele ausgibt neues personal wird nur in osteuropa eingestellt ja also im ernst ich weiß nicht
warum sich das der arbeitgeber erlauben kann eventuell ist es die kannst du kannst ja noch
mal schreiben aber eventuell ist es die region dass eben quasi ist mehr leute gibt oder oder
relativ viele leute gibt dass sie sich so so versauen können weil wenn es das wenn es
das nicht wäre wenn die leute einfach woanders hingehen es sei denn die bezahlung ist mega
mega nice ja und das man muss ja auch sagen diese ganzen outsourcen geschichten die sind
eigentlich schon wieder ausgesourced also es war ja vor so vor 15 jahren über jetzt ja
doch kommt hin da war es ja voll im trend da hat jeder bwl stonksmann was erzählt von
keine ahnung outsourcen nach indien und irgendwie herstellen lassen fragt mich nicht in bangladesh
oder sonst wie und gerade in der it wurden viele viele programmiert jobs nach indien
gepackt oder in andere länder ausgesourced und da hat man dann aber die nächsten fünf
jahre über festgestellt dass das dann doch nicht so gut funktioniert wie man sich das
gedacht hat ausnahmen bestätigen die regel es gibt sicherlich einige wo das gut funktioniert
hat aber du kannst halt nicht davon ausgehen dass wenn du quasi irgendwie da 15 in dahin
hockst diese zwei wochen programmieren dass da was gutes rauskommt und das hat man dann
so die letzten fünf sechs also über so fünf sechs jahre gemerkt dass es keine so gute
idee ist genauso genauso wie großraum bureaus arbeitsplätze hat man ja auch nach einer weile
gemerkt obwohl es mal eine zeit lang voll hip war dass es doch nicht so geil ist was eigentlich
jeder der mal dort gesessen hat und programmieren muss ich konzentrieren muss er nach fünf
fünf minuten weiß aber bw l stonks leute brauchen vielleicht manchmal bisschen länger
für und mittlerweile ist outsourcen eigentlich überhaupt nicht mehr angesagt was heute ausgesourced
wird ist oftmals nur so so klicker kram so was weiß ich irgendwelche so das was man
oftmals so auch bei crowdsourcing sieht so löse 50 captures für mich oder so was das
wird gerne ausgesourced so arbeiten auf diesem niveau und hotline outsourcen war eine zeitlang
auch mal beliebt wobei man halt sagen muss das ist echt problematisch also wir unser
netzwerkdienstleister hatte mal eine eine wie nennt man das eine eine eine vorgeschaltete
hotline vor der hotline in polen und mit denen konntest du nur polnisch oder englisch englisches
polnisch reden das war echt der wahnsinn wir haben ja wir haben ja bei uns glücklicherweise
einen native speaker also englisch und den also beim support wie gesagt ich arbeite nicht
beim support aber ich sitze in der nähe da krieg ich das immer mit und die haben ja zum
glück einen native speaker und die machen es am meisten so dass der solche anrufe anrufe
macht weil er eben gut mit englischen hotlines reden kann oder hat es nicht geschafft mit
der polnischen netzwerk hotline sich zu verständigen also als du kannst als englischer native speaker
probleme mit der englischsprachigen hotline das ist echt der wahnsinn gewesen die wollte
dass wir switch buch stabilieren ich glaube das habe ich euch schon mal erzählt was ist
kaputt eine switch ja und das war eine vorgeschaltete hotline zu eigentlichen netzwerk hotline ist
der wahnsinn das ist so geil also microsoft support tickets oder generell support tickets
bei bei größeren hersteller sind aber auch so geil hat jemand von euch mal in letzter
zeit mal das war irgendwie bei microsoft ticket aufgemacht und hat nicht die standard antwort
bekommen die standard antwort bei microsoft tickets wenn du microsoft support ist es übrigens
oracle und IBM das gleiche oder auch dell und hp du machst bei den großen herstellern
support ticket auf und sagst zum beispiel hey zugriff auf service xy ist langsam die antwort
die du bekommst ist bla bla bla vielen dank für ihr ticket wir haben jetzt den test gemacht
auf folgenden service und haben festgestellt der zugriff dauert fünf sekunden so also
fünf sekunden ist langsam und dann steht unten drunter wenn sie mit dieser antwort
zufrieden sind bitte schließen sie das ticket und da denke ich mir so hallo ihr habt als
antwort das geschrieben was ich als problem reingeschrieben habe also die schreiben immer
die erste antwort müsst ihr mal darauf achten die ersten antwort von support von support
tickets ist immer dass die euer ticket umformulieren bisschen was dabei schreiben im prinzip euch
noch mal bestätigen und dann fragen ob man das ticket schließen kann das ist aber wisst
ihr auch warum das so ist wisst ihr wisst ihr warum das so ist weil stonks es ist einzig
und allein stonks warum das so ist weil was gemessen wird bei support support tickets
hauptsächlich oder was auf was sich vertragsmäßig verständigt wird sind antwortszeiten nicht
etwa auf qualität oder sinnvolle antworten also du kriegst zum beispiel wenn du dir ein
wenn du dir support vertrag holst bei einem hersteller die sagen dann ja antwortszeiten
24 stunden 48 stunden oder keine ahnung zwei stunden für den super support vertrag keine
ahnung so und das müssen die einhaben und die antwortszeit ist nicht wie man vielleicht
als so naiver IT mensch wie ich sich das denken würde ist nicht etwa die zeit bis einer eine
qualifizierte sinnvolle antwort schreiben nein nein nein die zeit ist bis darauf reagiert
wird darauf reagiert werden kann auch sein das problem noch mal zu beschreiben und zu
fragen ob das ticket jetzt geschlossen werden kann also antwort das ist ultra bescheuert
diese regelung darauf überhaupt verdrege abzuschließen verstehe ich bis heute nicht
nur einzig eine aus stonks gründen ist das so
so ok also jetzt lassen wir uns gleich mal von level cap jibane ich scroll mal kurz chat
durch seht ihr ein bisschen vielleicht ja war ich habe ich damit noch null beschäftigt
batterie leasing ja das habe ich schon gecheckt dass man sich nicht einfach ein elektroauto
leasen kann das meistens man sich ein elektroauto liest plus noch mal extra gebühr für die
batterie bezahlt ja das das ist auch der grund warum ich überlegt habe da ich das
nicht bei mir also über meine meine firma lise weil ich bin mir gar nicht sicher ob
ich das auto jetzt irgendwie zehn jahre haben will ja das das haben wir schon mal
geguckt zusammen ja so kommt auch qualitativ was raus
du wirst ja nicht da reinfallen ja so ich glaube jetzt habe ich alles mit danke für
die ganzen subs ich ich gucke gleich nochmal nach jetzt müssen wir uns langsam level cap
jibane lassen ja ich gucke nur mal schnell wer alle subscribete hat huge subs subscribt
subscription also wen haben wir denn hier drei ist wieder am start dankeschön für den sub
der kuchen dienst den hatte ich schon aber trotzdem noch mal huge subscriptions doch nichts
übersehen würdest du lieber für vier stunden am tag 45 euro von zu hause verdienen oder
80 45 euro von zu hause verdienen oder 80 euro für was ne ganz klar vier stunden 45
euro da verdiene ich ja sogar noch pro stunde mehr wo ist denn der anreiz davon ins büro
zu fahren bei dieser bei dieser geschichte selbstverständlich selbst selbst selbstverständlich
würde ich würde ich das von daheim aus machen hast du vor bei deinem jetzigen arbeit geht
das meine ich nicht ich meine über meine eigene firma ließen nicht über mein arbeitgeber
ließen und über das natürlich auch das natürlich auch eine idee das ist natürlich auch eine
idee und dann vier überstunden machen kriege ich 90 euro verachtung kann trotzdem dauer
homeoffice machen beste beste so ok jetzt lassen wir uns level cap gbaiten auf gehts
level cap was davon ist level cap was davon ist das das level cap gbait gbait massive
gbait moment vierter achter das ist aber schon viel zu lang ja das ist das stimmt doch überhaupt
nicht das hat die ei überhaupt nicht gesagt die haben ich hab ich hab die news am rande
mitbekommen die haben irgendwie sowas gesagt dass sie auch an dass sie auch über free
to play varianten nachdenken oder irgendwie sowas der überschrift ist wieder massive gb
eanda tu hast werbung bei level cap buchen über product placement.com wirklich Was kosten
das echt zeig mal was kostet werbung bei level matchты schmilland angekommen kann
ich ein bisschen von ab besser ableiten vielleicht auch was ich so verlangen kann ich mein ich
kann natürlich nicht so viel verlangen wie careful cap aber auf youtube kann ich auch
So, wo denn? Hier, Product Placement.
Kostet?
Authentic Moments.
Ja, also bezahlt ist immer besonders authentischer.
Aber da steht nicht einfach das Geld da, das ist natürlich...
Stockfotos.
So, also, auf geht's.
Lassen wir uns mal chibaden.
Von Levelcap.
Was haben wir denn hier?
Ach, das kommt noch auf Konsole raus, okay.
Ja, für's wird mal Zeit für Titanfall 3.
Und wisst ihr worauf ich richtig Bock hab bei Titanfall 3?
Das ist die Kampagne zu spielen.
Ich fand die richtig gut im letzten.
Ich glaube bei ihm zahlt man schon 6-800€, das bezahlt sie ja bei mir schon.
Bei Levelcap muss das mehr sein.
Der spricht immer so ultra gelangweilt.
Ja, gut.
Also eins muss man denen ja sagen, free to anchor.
Die werden nie müde, sich neue Umschreibungen für die gleichen Sachen auszudenken, oder?
Das hört ja nie auf.
Ja, gut.
Ja, klar, weil man gehofft hat, man macht mit Battlefield 5 Big Service Game, was dann
keine Sau haben wollte.
Okay, keine Sau ist jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen hart.
Das haben ja schon Leute gespielt.
Das hat sich glaube ich auch ganz okay verkauft für das Debakel am Anfang.
Äh, gibt's da irgendwelche Statistiken zu?
Ich meine, das ist nicht wenig.
Aber nach dem Debakel am Anfang, wobei ja gut, ich meine, die hatten ja auch, das kann
man so, das kann man so aber gar nicht sagen, weil die haben ja nach, genau, die haben ja
auch total viele Sales, halbes, keine Ahnung, zwei Monate nach Release gemacht und sowas.
Also man muss schon sagen, also das hat die Aussagen, die, wie hieß er, Söderland, hieß
er Söderland, Söderland, irgendwie so, die er da gebracht hat am Anfang von Battlefield
5, die haben schon der Sache geschadet, ja.
Ich meine, du kannst den Leuten doch nicht erzählen, sie sollen es nicht holen.
Was ist das denn für eine Ansage an die Fans?
Du kannst doch deinen Fans nicht sagen, die quasi händeringend auf ein neues Game warten
und das nicht so cool finden, was gezeigt wird.
Du kannst denen doch nicht sagen, Leute, ihr seid ahnungslos, wenn es euch nicht gefällt,
dann fuck off und kauft es nicht.
Das ist doch, also das kann ich bis heute nicht verstehen.
Gut, der ist jetzt ja auch nicht mehr da.
Die haben jetzt ja irgendwie, ich glaube, die haben doch jetzt irgendwie einen Warzone
Stonks-Management-Typ damit dabei.
Das ist einfach Fail gewesen.
Ja, es war einfach, einfach so, so Two-Head schon, diese Ansage damals zu machen.
Returning to an every other year release cycle means that a new Battlefield game will launch
in 2020.
Warzone ist dead, Warzone macht ultra viel Kohle und Warzone hat auch viele Spieler.
Das Problem, was Warzone hat ist, Warzone ist Scheintod.
Wie soll man das sagen?
Ne, das ist das falsche Wort.
Warzone ist, Warzone trägt sich nur noch, ich weiß nicht, wie ich das ausdrücken soll.
Warzone wird gespielt, weil Warzone gespielt wird so.
Das wird aber, also dieser Zyklus wird sich nicht mal lange aufrechterhalten, glaube
ich zumindest.
Zombie, Zombie trifft es eigentlich ganz gut.
Also aktuell ist es so, Warzone wird gespielt, Streamer, Content Creator gehen auch auf Warzone.
Leute sehen das, probieren Warzone aus und die spielen, also viele spielen Warzone nicht
mehr, weil sie Warzone an sich mögen und spielen wollen, sondern nur noch, weil das
sich so ein selbstfütterndes System ist, Warzone.
Gut, ich will jetzt nicht auf alle ausweiten.
Du musst dir mal angucken, wenn du dir Content Creator anguckst, die sind so extrem abgefuckt
über dieses Spiel.
Und gar nicht mal über das Spiel an sich.
Klar, es gibt so komische Sachen wie Skins, die durchsichtig sind und so was.
Darüber auch.
Also Content Creator und Spieler sind über zwei Sachen abgefuckt.
Das erste ist die Unfähigkeit von Ravensoft, was Inhalte angeht.
Und das zweite ist, dass man Cheater-Problematiken gefühlt gar nichts dagegen unternimmt.
Das einzige, was man macht, ist ab und zu mal verkünden, wir haben jetzt 10.000 Accounts
gebannt, aber wen jucken denn innerhalb von drei Monaten 10.000 Accounts?
Das ist, das ist ungefähr so, wie wenn ich an Bahnhof einen Drogendealer festnehme in
Frankfurt und sage, ich habe das Drogenproblem am Hauptbahnhof gelöst.
Das ist ungefähr so ähnlich zu dem, wie wenn du 10.000 Leute bannst in Warzone.
Doch, doch, doch, das wird weiter Support bekommen, solange es gespielt wird.
Und ob es gespielt wird, hängt entscheidend davon ab, ob es Support bekommt.
Es wäre bescheuert, das Spiel nicht zu supporten, weil wenn es nicht supportet wird,
das Spiel ist geiler.
Was mein, du kannst heutzutage kein Game herausbringen und sagen, hey, das Spiel ist jetzt
released und bleibt jetzt in diesem Zustand und die Leute spielen das fünf Jahre.
Das funktioniert nicht.
Fortnite hat das vorgemacht.
Fortnite, die haben eine Weile lang wirklich jeden noch so größten Blödsinn, den ihnen
eingefallen ist, direkt ins Game geballert und haben es rausgebracht.
Ich meine, Fortnite ist vielleicht nicht mehr so das ultra riesen Ding, wie es noch vor
zwei Jahren war, eins bis zwei Jahren, aber es ist immer noch gut dabei.
Das liegt daran, dass es supportet wird.
Wenn die es nicht verkacken und den Spielern das liefern, was sie wollen, dann kannst du
das ohne Probleme auch länger spielen.
Das muss ja auch das Ziel sein.
Wie soll das sonst funktionieren?
Naja.
Das stimmt.
Es ist ja auch klar, warum man das macht.
Die hoffen natürlich, das ein bisschen auszubauen und die hoffen, ich vermute mal, dass das
so ist, dass du das auch über die Lebensdauer, falls, sie müssen sich auch absichern, falls
das mit Battlefield 2042, also dem Core Battlefield 2042 hier ist, dass du andere Teile noch am
Leben erhältst.
Ich meine, Warzone hat Modern Warfare gerettet.
Und ich glaube, die haben damit selbst nicht gerechnet, dass es so ein riesen Ding wird.
Und die haben das einzig Richtige gemacht.
Die haben gesagt, okay, das ist jetzt ja schon ausgekoppelt.
Wir koppeln das komplett ab von diesem eigentlich Modern Warfare, sondern machen da eine zweite
Schiene draus, wo du quasi immer Content releasen kannst aus allen möglichen, so werden
die das auch probieren.
Also, ich habe da mal, ich muss jetzt mal, der Chat sagt, bei Call of Duty verstehe ich
nicht, warum dieses Jahr schon wieder ein World War 2 Szenario kommt, das verstehe ich
auch nicht.
Ob es dieses Jahr aber überhaupt einen Call of Duty gibt, in der Form, wie wir uns das
vorstellen, ist fraglich.
Man hat nichts davon gehört und normalerweise ist ja schon in zwei Monaten Release.
Also, ich weiß nicht, was da abgeht, aber ich glaube, dieses Jahr ist nicht so das gewöhnliche
Call of Duty Jahr.
Da bin ich wirklich gespannt drauf, nicht so sehr auf das Game, sondern was da kommen
wird.
This could be seen as a massive problem for the game's competitive players.
Overall it's clear that DICE have room to improve Portal.
Lacking an essential feature like Spectator Mode is a massive oversight that partially
undermines the point of giving players these tools in the first place.
Hopefully DICE can add a spectator client after launch.
The console port of Insurgency Sandstorm might be launching on September 29th.
UK retailer Game currently lists an Xbox and Playstation 4.
Das habe ich mir gekauft vor ziemlich langer Zeit schon auf Steam und ich habe außer die
Trainingsmission noch nie was gespielt, aber ich fand's eigentlich cool.
Weiß auch nicht, warum ich mir das nie länger gegeben habe.
The launch date is September 29th, 2021, and unlike your run of the mill placeholder listings,
Game's website includes full details about what Sandstorm offers and wasn't taken down
as of writing this.
Typically when a retailer leaks a release date, the listing has almost no information and
is taken down quickly.
The console port of Sandstorm has been a long time coming after multiple delays pushed it
back by literally years.
The game has come into its own on PC as a robust tactical FPS title with tons of content, maps,
weapons and more.
Breaking info about the July 4th Apex Legends hack has untangled a web of conspiracies,
hacking and a plot to control Titanfall.
Titanfall 1 has been unplayable for years thanks to hackers deploying bots that crash
the game's entire server system.
The same hackers have also...
Moment!
Was haben Hacker davon, die Server-Systeme zu crashen?
Da kannst du ja nicht mal spielen mit deinen Hacks.
Wo ist denn da der Sinn von?
Ja!
in south korea bevor being shut down of course the massive wrinkle in their plan is that they're the reason that
titanfall one is unplayable the hackers are essentially attacking respawn for problems that
well they themselves created it sounds like there are two overlapping groups of hackers here
one is a random sea of people massive wrinkle in their plan is that they're the reason that
titanfall one is maliciously attacking titanfall just for fun and the other is a more organized
group taking time fall over by force will prevent the first group from ruining their fun to accomplish
that they attack titanfall unplayable the hackers are essentially attacking respawn for problems that
well they themselves created it sounds like there are two overlapping groups of hackers here
one is a random sea of people man apex legends using the same methods perpetuating the problem
now there's actually a lot more details about the story but it's way more complicated than we have
time to cover in today's video if you're interested maliciously attacking titanfall just for fun
and the other is a more organized group taking time fall over by force will prevent the first
group from ruining their fun to accomplish that they attack titanfall and reading more we've linked
a summary of the whole ordeal below that has some resources and info split gates developers
finally increased server capacity early yesterday afternoon before the update went live players
could be stuck in the login queue now there's actually a lot more details about the story but
it's way more complicated than we have time to cover in today's video if you're interested in
reading more we've linked a summary of the whole ordeal below that has some resources and info
split gates developers finally increased server capacity early yesterday
for hours now you'll be waiting a maximum of 30 minutes there are also many more slots for
players to log in so the chances of ending up in queue are also significantly reduced so
so
for hours now you'll be waiting a maximum of 30 minutes there are also many more slots for
players to log in so the chances of and had a chance to play yet it's a bit like halo were
invited by valve to check out their upcoming portable console the steam deck and calling it
a portable console does being up in queue are also significantly reduced so far so reddit drama
already drama is always good queue times down to less than two minutes this is excellent news
for people interested in the game that haven't really seemed to do the device justice though
like no it's not at all the steam deck is a normal pc with cutting edge internals reviewers are
cutting edge is had a chance to play yet it looks a bit like halo were invited by valve to check out
their upcoming portable console the steam deck and calling it a portable console does maybe a
bit a bit too much good a top-notch experience with games like doom eternal capable of running
at a stable 60 it really seemed to do the device justice though like no it's not at all the steam
deck is a normal pc with cutting edge internals reviewers are cutting edge is maybe a bit
a bit too much good a top-notch experience with games like doom eternal capable of running at a
stable 60 fps the steam deck runs steam os and valve has made many updates that tail has made many
updates that tailor it to the console like experience it has a built-in menu for adjusting
screen brightness volume wireless connectivity and more but the most significant improvement
is that the os directly integrates with all of the devices inputs touch sensitive analog sticks
touch pads traditional face buttons and a touch screen all work seamlessly in game and in the
general os it sounds like valve is gearing up to change the portable gaming landscape in the ways
that they said they were going to in the reveal it's just now being confirmed by reviewers the pc
version of rust just got a big monthly update additions include procedurally generated underwater
bases submarines fishing sharks and a ton of fixes you'll need a submarine to reach the new
underwater bases subs can be purchased from boats and two people submarines can be armed with
torpedoes and players can use a spear gun to run themselves underwater no word on when this
update rust hat ja mal kurzzeitig wieder ein hype vor halb jahr oder so als die ganzen großen us
streamer alle rusts gespielt haben auf so einem persistent server da gab es ja aber auch krass
drama drum wieder ey das war so lustig
console things are changing for player unknowns battlegrounds and by changing we mean the games
name the developers have updated the game's social media and store pages renaming the game pub g
battlegrounds and considering that the bg in pub g stands for battlegrounds well that would
make it say player unknowns battlegrounds battlegrounds the developers say that they're
doing this to unify the game's branding under the pub g umbrella and highlight pub g new state as
an example and i think i made some comment about this when pub g was first coming out
and it's a miracle that the game has done so well but now they're having to deal with the ramifications
of such an obscure title and before we move on to this week's final story i just like to remind
you that we'd always love to hear what you think about these stories are you excited about the
future of battlefield have you placed an order for a steam deck leave a comment letting us know
sony held a private conference discussing the upcoming psvr 2 according to reports it'll offer
a 2000 by 2040 pixel per eye oled display genauso genauso sieht das immer aus wenn man wenn man so
was aufzieht eye tracking in 110 degree field of view the psvr will use eye tracking to increase
performance by dropping the render resolution when you aren't looking the psvr 2 will ship
with updated controllers that feature finger tracking like valve and oculus's more recent
devices it'll also work with original psvr titles sony are looking for a triple a developers to
offer their games with optional vr modes like hitman 3 did psvr will be revealed next year
ich habe nicht mal eine aktuelle playstation ich kann auch nicht mal
selbst wenn ich spielen wollte dann könnte ich das nicht spielen sehe ich einen dafür eine
konto eine ps5 zu kaufen ich mache nicht mehr den fehler wie letzte konsolen generation letzte
konsolen generation habe ich mir zu release wie gesagt ich habe sie noch liegen hier day one
edition 2013 xbox one und ps4 ich habe jetzt ich habe das damals alles zum release gekauft ich
hatte es nie an so gut wie nie also ich habe das ich habe kaum was drauf gespielt komplett
komplett für den arsch so next so was gucken wir uns jetzt an das habe ich mal aufgemacht
der titel interessant klingt ich habe absolut kein plan davon
was i paid dass das habe ich auch nur aufgemacht weil der titel interessant klingt die bewertungen
sind nicht so geil i paid game developers on fiverr to make the same game das gucken wir jetzt das
ist bestimmt bestimmt tschibetitel bei der bewertung so i'm sure you're familiar with fiverr if you're
not fiverr is essentially a website where you can pay people for freelance services like graphic
design animation and most importantly game development so i thought it would be a good
idea to pay different game developers on fiverr to make the exact same game ja oder oder um bus
bass bass bass lines zu bei wie hier wie heißt der kerl noch mal epic epic bass und fiverr kriegst
dich mal zusammen i would provide them all with the same day wie und dann eben nur 5 ja ist der
typ der wie fiverr fiverr genau den meine ich brief and it was up to them to make durch die
videos habe ich sogar fiverr gefunden ich wusste gar nicht dass es fiverr gibt but before we get
into the video i use to make my games and the answer is game maker who have also sponsored today's
video game maker is the fastest das gibt's noch and friendliest cross-platform game development
software wait a minute you already create games or you're looking to start game maker is the
software moment das verwechsel ich jetzt mit rpg maker das habe ich jetzt mit rpg maker verwechselt
wo früher die ganzen fünf fünfzehnjährigen ihre edgy anime games drinne gemacht haben ich habe
das verwechselt und was programmiert man das ist das ist das ja was nee if you's null klaren
monkaS was zum was ist das für eine sprache
wat de
das ist irgendwas eigenes oder das ist irgendwas ein eigenes man sieht ja auch keine keine
dateiendung die formatierung ist auch pence champ ja aber ok das muss irgendwas eigenes
to make games can be done in the one software coding game design it can all be done in game maker with
no barrier to entry making game maker studio to the ultimate 2d development environment another
feature that makes game maker special is their drag-and-drop system a game without range of both
video and rick so you can't games the load and read it get fixes to command you can't get
das noch das ist halt ist es halbe video game maker sponsor shape oder wie so here's the plan i was
going to write up a brief for a game find three different fire game developers send them the brief
and play and review habe ich ja auch schon mal probiert ich wollte ich wollte ja auch mal ein
video machen über über fiverr ich habe damals versucht elf programmierern in hauptsächlich
würde ich mal sagen vom namen her war das in der oder irgendwie aus dieser ecke ich habe einfach
nach den günstigsten gefiltert so und ich hatte damals elf leuten eine beschreibung geschickt für
eine anwendung die sie programmieren sollten und zwar war was relativ was relativ einfach ist das
habe ich nicht im stream gemacht ich habe die ergebnisse gezeigt im stream das war was relativ
einfach ist ich wollte dass die über die twitch chat also über die twitch chat api highlighten
also das sollte man sollte sich mit dem browser darauf connecten können und das ding sollte den
twitch chat filtern und nachrichten an einen selbst highlighten also im prinzip das gleiche
was ffz oder so als als plugin macht das ist einfach also das sind das sind keine 150 zeilen
code das ist wirklich easy as fuck ich habe ja wir haben selbst im stream programmiert und es war
unglaublich zu sehen wie unfähig die sich alle angestellt haben ich kann es aber verstehen ich
würde mich mit der problematik für 8 euro 40 auch nicht beschäftigen aber wenn ich anbiete für 8
euro 40 dass ich eine complete application erstelle dann sollte ich auch machen oder ich
sollte es halt nicht für 8 euro 40 anbieten so und der einzige der es geliefert hat am ende war
dann auch noch komplett unbrauchbar was da rausgekommen ist start with the game brief the endless
runner genre has been a popular game genre over the past few years so i wanted to make one with
guns the name of the game i wanted to create was gunner runner and the brief is as follows an
endless runner platform game but with shooting elements whilst jumping over obstacles in an
endless runner gameplay environment you also have a gun and can shoot enemies for extra points some
enemies also have weapons and tried to shoot at you the game should get progressively harder as the
run goes on please be creative please also use royalty-free graphics slash assets or graphics
slash assets you create and give me permission to use perfect so essentially an endless runner
was da rauskommt also also nach meinen erfahrungen mit den programmierern auf fiverr die ich da mit
dem kleinen test gemacht habe ich weiß nicht glaube da kommt nichts gutes bei rum vielleicht
ist es aber auch so dass er jetzt wirklich glück hatte und da einen erwischt hat der erahnt hat
dass es für den youtube video oder so ein fein when i first started looking through the fiverr
gigs i noticed a lot of them had something in common the starting app price would be pretty cheap yeah especially for a game development gig however their first package was simply bug fixes if you wanted a game developed it would cost upwards of one thousand dollars however i tried contacting das ist ja mehr das ist ja mehr als manche kickstarter projekte wollen für ein komplettes mmo es gibt auf kickstarter so viel projekte wo einer sagt ich will ein spiel bauen und brauche 1000 euro oder
für das verstehe ich auch nicht klauen 97 danke schön für den zap aber ich unterstelle den auf kickstarter noch nicht mal scam den meisten glaubt die meisten haben einfach überhaupt kein gefühl dafür wie viel arbeit und wie viel aufwand das ist
vermute ich mal sellers anyway but when i told them my budget for the project i didn't get 5 euro null i eventually found someone that was interested i found a gig contacted the seller we agreed on ten dollars for my project requirements and with that our first order was made for the second order i found another gig that was ten dollars sent my offer the seller accepted and we had our second order for the third order the seller offered
to do it for 25 dollars and our third and final order was made within a week i had all three games back and i was ready to play all right so here we are with the first game endless runner so let's start by checking out how to play so don't run into blocks
das sieht aus das sieht aus wie den java spiel nicht java java einen flash ein flash spiel das sieht aus wie wie in ein flash spiel von 1998 wo jemand versucht hat mit der mit der action wie ist diese action script ide was zusammenzuklicken
das ist der kram speichert auch automatisch enemies for extra points up to jump right to shoot and f11 for full screen perfect so let's start and give it a shot okay i like it so far so let's shoot nice
naja komm für zehn euro was willst du erwarten der speichert du musst mal gucken ob du nicht temporäre dateien hast also also chain or zwei sachen pie charm was du machen kannst ist je in deine lokale history von
einer datei macht control schrift a gehen wir in die in die genau das was choose my name sagt je in die history du hast eine lokale history auch ohne get repo für änderungen in der datei und du müsstest mal gucken ob
der irgendwelche temporären dateien rumliegen aber ich meine für zehn euro kann sich nicht beschweren oder für zehn euro oder für fünf euro oder was auch immer kann ich ja nichts großartig erwarten der hat einfach der platziert einfach random den gegner irgendwo und random so einen so einen hügel und lässt es durch scrollen
we got our distance and we got our score so let's restart and let's have another shot alright oh this is getting tricky i mean was willst du denn für fünf euro haben ja obstacle and that is this reoccurring block and ich drücke auch laufen control s they're not really an obstacle they're just there for extra points you know the game's pretty simple but it does the trick it's pretty much what i asked ja und ich weit vor fünf oder zehn euro kann sich echt nicht beschweren
or it's an endless runner with shooting mechanics the enemies don't really attack they're just there for points but that's cool as well but yeah overall pretty fun i'm about to hit a high score up there we go okay cool game one was called endless runner this game had a nice pixel art design and the game also got progressively faster and more difficult as time went on which helped with the gameplay the endless runner system was good the shooting worked well and overall the game was simple yet effective for only ten dollars this game was
great as a possible prototype or starting point of a future project
ja also für zehn euro zehn dollar game gunner runner so let's press any key to start hat er hat er eine korona maske auf nee das ist eine sonnenbrille so we can jump we can also shoot ich hätte jetzt erwartet we we geht's noch so wer hätte noch gedacht dieses ding fällt jetzt runter wenn man drauf springt
so shoot we can collect gems this is pretty good so far i see that our first enemy let's take him out i think it's a live system i just died but i respond to have a heart that's awesome also ganz ehrlich für zehn euro kannst du dich da wirklich nicht beschweren
i really like the endless runner obstacles how they sort of randomly generated that's pretty cool was born sogar leben do that continue playing on also da kannst du dich ja nur wirklich nicht beschweren drüber
what i like about both the games so far is that the distance run is not exactly your score you there you can do other things to get more score so you can obviously kill enemies in this one and collect gems man this feels
like a great arcade game like it feels like um it's got a consistent gameplay loop so you can basically keep playing for as long as you can maintain uh your hearts so we've we've just died then as long as we collect another also ich
vermute der der typ hat erahnt dass für ein youtube video ist ob das wirklich schon pfeifer ist oder gestellt für youtube man weiß es nie aber der typ hat ja geahnt es muss für ein youtube video sein weil ich hätte
mir nicht so viel mühe gegeben für zehn euro ganz ehrlich which is great it's great for doing high scores and the variety in obstacles is really awesome so i like this one let's
let's try to go for 10 000 see if we can get 10 000
all right we're down to one half is that's
possible uh the game's actually getting faster i've noticed that's awesome so it does get progressively difficult it's almost like they took the brief and
did everything i asked for we got a new high score it wasn't quite 10 000 but that is awesome the thing i really like about this game is
that it gets faster as it goes on which makes it increasingly difficult and yeah that was awesome game two was called gunner runner which was the name i
requested and man this game was awesome this game felt polished with an overall consistent and clean art style great animations and a clean gui the endless
runner level design was incredible with different platforming obstacles to constantly yeah also kannst du also wirklich für zehn euro
my the fuck not only could you shoot enemies but they could shoot you back this meant you had something else to think about whilst playing
das ist schon so ein bisschen man merkt ja schon dass das nicht wirklich polischt ist aber ich mein zehn euro da würde ich noch nicht mal
noch nicht mal das überhaupt erwähnen die punkte die mich die mich stören
not just the platforming obstacles this game would work great as a full release and for only ten dollars
it was definitely worth it i might even turn this into a full game what do you guys think
vielleicht hat er aber auch glück gehabt und irgendjemand hat schon mal für sich so
ein testprojekt gemacht in der richtung hat gedacht ah ok wenn das jetzt irgendjemand
mal haben will dann kann ich ihm das gleich verkaufen
all right and here's the third game oh nice we're already straight into it so let's go for
it okay okay we hold down the arrow keys i am pretty sure what i need to do also ganz ehrlich ich hätte auch eher an
ein 2d game gedacht bei der anfrage und to each platform before it disappears and try to shoot as many enemies
off as we can i think the enemies will just try to push us off or try to prevent us from going
by this by this sogar noch eine recht wie soll ich sagen noch irgendwie so ein cleveren gameplay kniff hat das ganze hier
we can we can just leave them there we can all hang out i've just fallen off i've just fallen off all right
let's uh let's go again actually we're gonna shoot them off anyway because you know why not that's
that's why dem platform die verschwindung ist ich finde das ist aus ruckel das ruckel high score of 14
that works game three was called runner shooter and this game had a unique approach to my request
essentially different platforms spawn endlessly with enemies that try to kill you and you have to
keep running to new platforms before your current platform disappears you can also shoot enemies to
knock them off the platforms and for each platform you survive you get a point the game gets
progressively difficult as the old platforms disappear faster and faster is the game very clean with a nice design and a unique gameplay experience
was incredible generell ohne scheiß alle drei alle drei gehen für das geld nicht mal mehr
als in ordnung es ist deutlich mehr als man überhaupt erwarten konnte so those were our three games from
fiverr if you enjoyed this video and want more fiverr videos leave a like what did you guys think of
the game just let me know in the comments and you can also subscribe on screen now i've got some videos you may enjoy so feel free to check
ja gut
da hat er recht die namen könnte man wirklich erwähnen wisst ihr was vielleicht ist es doch gefaked
sonst hätte man noch die namen der entwickler mal zeigen können das stimmt vielleicht ist es doch
vielleicht ist es echt gefakt was macht der sonst der bastel sonst selber games vielleicht ist es gefakt
das hat er einfach erstellt und gesagt es ist von fiverr weil sich fiverr gut verkauft
das könnte echt sein gebaited vielleicht wurden vielleicht wurden wir einfach krass gebaited mit
dem video vielleicht hat er auch genau vielleicht hat seine alten projekte verwertet
okay was was können wir uns als nächstes antun
die gaming night der jungen union ja das war das war massivster pains champ
okay was ist nur mit pokémon ich habe keine ahnung ich kenne das ich spiele kein pokémon
this video may break the algorithm ist das so wait 25 percent and turn on close captioning but if you don't do this none of the wait a minute go erstmal die lautstärke einstelle this video please turn your playback speed to 25 percent and turn on close captioning if you don't do this none of this video will make sense at all
okay alter warte mal was ist das playback speed 25 prozent
das ist mir aber zu anstrengend zum anhören
das ist mir zu anstrengend zum anhören das ist zu ihr ihr ihr pains champ ja monarch s aber richtig
bestimmt rick roll ja ich dachte auch erst dass ganz ehrlich ich dachte auch dass da jetzt kommt
bitte stellen das video runter auf 25 prozent und bla bla bla und dann nach zwanzig minuten kommt
kam aber nicht
reaction das da
ranking every twitch meta from least to most entertaining tier list
18 minuten border setz bisschen lang das beste twitch meta ist definitiv nicht hot tube streams
offer watch war richtig cool als jeder auf erwacht gespielt hat als auf erwacht
neu war und man gedacht hat blizzard verkackt nicht was war das beste twitch meta weiß ich
müsste mir gedanken drüber machen wir gucken jetzt erst was anderes 18 minuten
so mein fazit zur new world beta das geht das geht auch noch in zehn minuten das will ich mir
mal angucken weil ich mal wissen will was andere deutsch deutschsprachige leute das mehr gespielt
haben zu dem zu dem spiel sagen das das das gucken wir uns jetzt an das ist das video zu
diesem apple im hintergrund scannen nach kinder pornos ich weiß nicht ob ihr das mitbekommen
habt die ging into secret windows folders mal gucken ich weiß nicht ob er das mitbekommen hat
aber apple hat angekündigt heißt hat einen guten hat einen guten artikel dazu gab apple hat angekündigt
dass sie ja da haben sie haben sie einen guten artikel zu ja gut apple lasst den scheiß genau
also apple hat angekündigt dass sie die iphones im hintergrund scannen wollen nach kinder pornos
oder eben ja das das ist ja schon das nächste problem oder eben nach dem was apple dafür hält
oder nach was auch immer diese software macht man weiß es nicht so in der cloud ist das vollkommen
normal da müssen das glaube ich sogar die hersteller in usa schon machen aber es geht
jetzt nicht um die cloud sondern es geht wirklich um das eigene gerät also die wollen auf dem eigenen
gerät das ganze dass das das ganze scannen und das ist natürlich schon mal ein starkes stück
der schritt quasi von der cloud zu wir durch wie durch durch porsten alle lokalen geräte mit einer
software wo keine ahnung davon hat was die genau macht ja und was da eigentlich alles gescannt wird
das bringt doch nichts wenn die das ankündigen du meinst mal die leute dann wegrennen die wirklich
damit was zu tun haben ja da ist das ist das ist ein interessanter punkt und apple würde es
wahrscheinlich auch nicht machen wenn die damit nicht mehr planen würden warum sollten die so was
sonst bauen das ist genau das ist genau eines der probleme wo ich mich auch gefragt habe was
ist wenn eine familie am see ist und ihre kinder fotografiert es ist es ist schwierig ist es
generell schwierig mal gucken was er dazu sagt vielleicht muss ich das video wieder skippen
weil der der der ergießt sich manchmal in ein bisschen zu detailliertem geflame über kleine
punkte ja also der hat dann der hat der hat ein großes thema und pickt sich dann zwei sachen raus
über dir zehn minuten flamt mal gucken es ist auch ein ansatz wobei du dann neue sachen schon
mal gar nicht findest ich gehe davon aus dass es wir können uns das video machen also ich gehe
mal davon aus dass wenn apple so was macht die damit noch mehr planen als als diese eine sache
und warum also warum ich prinzipiell mit solchen sachen ja auf auf kriegsfuß stehe ist er muss
natürlich noch mal sagen dass ich selbstverständlich nicht dafür bin dass die leute so sachen auf ihrem
smartphone scheren sollen oder sowas ist ja ganz klar das ist zu recht wird das hart bestraft
und das sollte es hier keine keine einladung sein aber man muss sich mal überlegen was das
was das heißt also sprich im endeffekt bedeutet dass er das scannen auf den smartphones ist
ein eingriff somit die innerste privatsphäre der leute von privaten bildern und das wird halt unter
dem deckmantel gemacht man möchte das ja gegen kinderpornos machen das ist ein
das ist eine taktik die hat man schon öfters gesehen man fängt immer an mit dass es gegen
kinderpornos als nächstes kommt dass es gegen terroristen als nächstes kommt das ist gegen
schwerverbrecher und mörder und sowas und dann wird das immer weiter aufgeweicht in in salami
taktik bis im endeffekt quasi jeder alles kennt das heißt wenn du mit sowas anfängst und schon
mal prinzipiell jeden benutzer unter unter verdacht stellst was da am ende rauskommt ist fraglich ich
glaube nämlich dass es zur kinderpornobekämpfung an sich wahrscheinlich gar nicht mal so großartige
auswirkungen hat ja mal gucken was er dazu sagt außerdem ist es nicht aufgabe von apple das muss
man ja auch noch mal ganz klar sagen es ist nicht die aufgabe das habe ich übrigens auch das habe
ich auch gestern von dem video gesagt was mir ein bisschen auf den keks geht es ist nicht die
aufgabe eines privaten unternehmens polizei zu spielen das ist genau das gleiche wie dass
man youtube und provide an immer mehr ja als ausgabe aufgaben aus dem polizeilichen umfeld was
abgleich kontrolle sperren und so betrifft auf die aufs auge drückt
da haben die da haben die da haben die riesen riesen wellen die letzten letzten zwei jahre
drüber gemacht wie krass pro privacy sie sind apple when there have been multiple accounts of them refusing to unlock the iphones of killers and known terrorists in order to help the fbi with their investigations and this implies two things first it implies that an iphone that is properly encrypted most likely in the bfu mode is very difficult if not impossible for the alphabet boys to unlock because you
gotta think why would they even ask for apple's help in unlocking these phones if they couldn't just do it themselves and this also implies that either apple has designed the device in such a way that even they themselves can't unlock it to retrieve data or they are just das ist ja das was was kim auch ausprobiert hat mit mega so nach dem motto wir machen es kleinzeitig verschlüsselt oder wir machen so dass wir selbst keine möglichkeit haben zu wissen was da abgeht beziehungsweise selbst keinen zugriff drauf haben
das hat insofern den scham du bist eigentlich fein raus wenn irgendwelche behörden was von dir wollen
die wollen die wollen nicht nur i cloud scan i cloud scan und cloud scan ist schon alter hut die wollen lokal
dein iphone bilder ordner zum beispiel durchscannen und nachdem das ja eine proprietäre software ist wo
niemand weiß was sie macht und was sie genau sucht und und wie sie funktioniert halte ich
das für höchst fragwürdig das stellt halt auch prinzipiell mal jeden benutzer irgendwie
unter pauschal unter verdacht da muss man sich fragen will man das vor allem mit den erfahrungen
ähnlicher ähnlicher dinger die immer weiter aufgeweicht werden so nach dem motto wir machen
vorrat datenspeicherung für schwerste verbrechen und so nach dem motto du hast illegalen film
runtergeladen ja zum klug haben wir das alles gespeichert übertriebener fall
die bilder bei dem typ immer im video
warum existieren so bilder überhaupt die hat er noch nicht selbst gemalt für das video
ok warum kann man sich einfach so nennen was es ist wo jeder was drunter versteht
ja kann ich auch verstehen ich kann das voll und ganz verstehen wenn man dafür ist also für diese
für die prinzipielle ab für diese aktion ich meine es kann ja niemand wirklich außer leute
die die sowas selbst konsumieren dagegen also für die verbreitung sein kann man ja nicht wenn
man irgendwie noch halbwegs normal bei verstand es kann man nicht dafür sein es ist aber halt
wieder in dem fall die details dies ausmachen also erstens sollte ein privates unternehmen
polizei spielen das ist die erste fragen wie man sich stellen muss und was allgemein bei
solchen ja bei solchen aktionen was man sich immer fragen muss ist rechtfertigt diese eine
aktion das pauschale unter verdacht stellen von allen benutzern und wie hoch sind überhaupt da
die erfolgs aussichten ich denke dass das sind frage muss man stellen und man muss das auch
gegeneinander abwägen ob es das problem löst wage ich mal zu bezweifeln weil gerade jetzt
nach dieser ankündigung wird doch keiner der da ernsthaft in diesem business was auch immer
unterwegs ist dass jetzt noch über sein iphone machen also da hat er nicht unrecht und das ist
ja auch schon ein valider punkt ja und man muss auch gucken ihr wisst ich bin auch immer dagegen
so nach dem motto irgendwie mehr befugnisse auszuweiten und blau und hier und da mehr
überwachen aber natürlich muss man auch gucken dass die polizei mit der zeit gehen kann man kann
jetzt nicht sagen so nach dem motto man man macht quasi keinerlei zugeschnitte technische
zugeständnisse um dass die polizei quasi auch aktuelle sachen besser handhaben kann ja also
da kommt man ja nicht drumherum aber muss halt immer abwägen wie sieht der konkrete fall aus
und wo ich halt wo ich halt die größten bedenken habe bei solchen aktionen ist dass man anfängt
mit kinderpornos wo niemand was dagegen sagen kann dann fängt man an und sagt das nächste
ist wir benutzen das auch zu terrorismus abwehr da kann auch eigentlich niemand wirklich was
gegen sagen danach kommt wir benutzen es zum aufklären schwerer straftaten da kann auch
schon eigentlich fast niemand was gegen sagen und dann geht es und dann geht es immer weiter immer
weiter bis dann irgendwann rauskommt oder hast du einen film daung daung geladen davon ein
screenshot gemacht in your face das ist dann zwar noch ein bisschen hin aber wir haben es
gesehen dass so aufweichprozesse gehen fließend langsam ineinander über und irgendwann sind es
dann irgendwelche belanglosigkeiten wurde ein iphone für durchsucht wird
deswegen muss man sich hier tatsächlich fragen ist es nicht besser das schon gleich von
anfang an zu unterbinden ich weiß gar nicht was die amis ich muss jetzt mal ich weiß gar nicht
was die amis immer mit ihren waffen haben eines der hauptargumente bei den amis für waffenbesitz
ist ja weil andere waffen besitzen das ist ja das ist ja so das ist ja das standard argument bei
denen ich muss also bei den amis die sagen ich muss eine waffe besitzen weil andere besitzen
ja auch waffen und und und freedom und ich muss mich verteidigen ja also das ist so das ist so die
standardgeschichte was ich halt nicht verstehe ist wie das wie die das immer so verargumentiert
kriegen weil ich mein es gibt ja länder gucken wir mal bei uns in deutschland sich das ganze an
da funktioniert das ja auch das also das das funktioniert ja hier auch also hier ist nicht
jeder jeder zweite mit einer mit einer maschinenpistole oder zumindest mit einer
pistol oder was immer bewaffnet unterwegs und es gibt dementsprechend auch deutlich weniger schießereien
und und überfälle mit waffen und sonst was und die geschichte was dann auch immer kommt so wenn
einer in ein haus einbricht mit einer waffe das passiert hier ja auch bloß dass die halt vielleicht
hier nicht unbedingt mit waffen einbrechen und eigentlich selten interesse haben dass man anwesend
ist ich weiß nicht also dass das kann das kann ich bei den amis immer nicht so genau verstehen
also ich habe total viele videos gesehen da heißt so nach dem was machst du wenn dich einer mit
einer waffe überfällt und die standardantwort ist dann ich brauche selbst eine waffe wäre es
nicht viel sinnvoller wenn der typ dich erst gar nicht überfällt oder noch besser dich vielleicht
nicht mit einer waffe überfällt natürlich die hat die etwas bei den amis noch mehr probleme du
musst irgendwelche gesetze ändern was da eh immer größere akt ist und damit kenne ich mich auch
ehrlich gesagt überhaupt nicht aus aber so dieses dieses ich brauche eine waffe weil alle andere
eine waffe verstehe nicht naja okay kommen wir weiter just about anything what if certain memes
become criminalized like how the one on the right is in china well my thousands of controversial
memes that i've collected over the years get me arrested and sent to a re-education camp was
bin ich sehend was und was spricht er okay ich bin auch geil dass sie sich immer so abkürzung
dafür ausdenken warum kann man das denn nicht nicht nicht beim name nennen
das ist jetzt das was ich bei was was ich bei fotos mal also das muss ich jetzt noch mal kurz
so hier also detection method privacy in mind ja super super krass private erstmal alles zu
durchsuchen instead of sehr moment moment die wollen uns jetzt als vorteil verkaufen lokale
devices zu zu durchsuchen oder was und device matching using database okay das heißt die
durchsuche nicht wirklich die bilder die machen eine hashsumme über die bilder und gleichen das
mit einer datenbank ab dann ist die nächste frage okay was was landet alles in dieser datenbank also
wie sicher ist das was in dieser datenbank ist dass das eben auch sie sam ist gut wer auch wer
auch immer das ist keine ahnung irgendeine kokona organization keine ahnung je nachdem was sie
für hashes verwenden wie sieht es mit kollisionen aus gut ich meine wenn die was halbwegs aktuelles
normales verhältnisses mit kollisionen nahezu ausgeschlossen der chat sagt aber den haschwert
kann man doch auch manipulieren wie willst du das machen du kannst hashes nicht nicht dass
er gerade der sinn von hashes es ist äußerst schwierig das hashes zu manipulieren an sich geht
ja geht ja mit dem mit dem mit dem klartext inhalt e nur beschränkt also du kannst versuchen hasch
kollisionen zu finden dass du zweimal den gleichen input zum gleichen hasch kriegst aber die
wahrscheinlichkeit ist sehr sehr sehr sehr unwahrscheinlich dass du da was findest
kannst du nicht einfach random pixel schwarz machen doch das gibt einen komplett anderen hasch
ach so meint ihr das ach so ja das kannst du machen
es gibt aber da weiß ich aber nicht wie das funktioniert es gibt ja so verschiedene
watermark verfahren die du also schlecht rausbekommst durch ändern des materiales also das sind
das sind also sachen die für copyright verstöße verwendet werden also trotz encoding kompression
zippen entzippen wie auch immer gut zippen entzippen ist verlustfrei bleiben watermarks
erhalten also man könnte zum beispiel versuchen ich weiß nicht wie sie es machen quasi spezielle
punkte in diesen bildern zu indemnifizieren die die bilder recht eindeutig ausmachen die man
schlecht durch zusätzliche manipulator wie auch immer es wird auf jeden fall einen gewissen
grad der fehler anfälligkeit geben und dann wird das bild hochgeladen wenn es match oder wie
ok bevor i device matching process ist performt ok
aha ok die scannen vor dem upload
das ist schon die erste falsche sind keine reinen hashes von bildern es handelt sich
um im ersten step durch die analysierte features in bildern ok dann ist das ja das wie ich mir
das ungefähr schon gedacht habt du suchst dir merkmal aus den bildern raus die du möglichst
schlecht quasi verfälschen kannst ja und davon dann die hashes und genau genau ja das klingt
auch sinnvoller
ja gut dann ergibt das dann ergibt das ja sogar sinn was ich gesagt habe weil wenn du einfach nur
einzelne pixel ändern könntest und die machen da irgendwie schad 256 drüber das wäre irgendwie
unsinnig ja dafür muss dann der inhalt gescannt werden oder zumindest zumindest musst du die
bildinformation auf gewisse merkmale untersuchen ja was im prinzip auf scannen rauskommt ja da habe
ich auch meine da habe ich da habe ich wirklich die bedenken wie wollen sie das machen also
ist jetzt apple wirklich die polizei neuerdings
ja gut so einfach ist es ja nicht wisst ihr wisst ihr was hier genau das genau das habe
ich mir auch gerade gesagt wisst ihr was wird was wieder richtig heftig sein wird die leute
dieses am ende weil das habe ich nämlich schon gelesen dass am ende auch wirklich noch echte
menschen kontrollieren sollen ob das wirklich ein verstoß ist und die arme leute die diesen
scheiß wieder kontrollieren müssen es gibt genug berichte von facebook wie heißt es diese gruppe
diese diese facebook diese facebook content moderator typen da gibt es genug berichte
davon dass leute wirklich komplette psychische störungen entwickelt haben weil sie sich zu viel
facebook scheiße angucken mussten und ich meine die leute laden auf facebook alles hoch die laden
einfach alles hoch und das ist ja nicht nur auf facebook ist auf youtube und twitch und so
wahrscheinlich überall auch so
ja und da haben wir gerade schon gelernt dass es in dem
fall so nicht
jetzt rennt da wahrscheinlich noch ein bisschen über apple
also ich bin bei diesem thema echt so ein bisschen hin und her gerissen ich finde es
wichtig dass man natürlich mehr dagegen macht was ich nicht weiß ob es gerechtfertigt ist
erstens dass apple polizei spiel und zweitens dass man alle leute irgendwie unter generalverdacht
stellt und das dritte ist es fraglich inwieweit das jetzt dazu führen wird dass man da mehr
leute erwischt bei das ist auf jeden fall ein schwieriges thema aber ich bin prinzipiell
dagegen dass anpeter irgendwie lokale wahllos irgendwie lokale die devices scannen mag in
dem fall nicht so sein aber es ist ein wie soll ich sagen ein dampfbruch ja wenn apple mit so
was anfängt dann ist microsoft auch als nächstes mit am start google garantiert auch mit am start
und für immer dass ist das das ist mein bedenken dabei für immer weiter aufgeweichte dinger
irgendwann wird gescannt ob du nicht den raubkopierten film abspielst und hast dann direkt so eine
einsatzkommando vor der tür also fotos in die cloud bringen ja nix es geht ja es geht ja auch
lokal ums durchsuchen das ist es ist echt komplizierte schwieriges thema
so jetzt einmal zu etwas erfreulicheren sachen was gucken wir uns jetzt an
katzen katzen video beste sponsored by insta 360 my cat is up to something i don't know what
but i can see in those bd little eyes of his and i'm gonna find out i've tried gps tracking him but
i think he was onto me so then i set up night vision cameras all over my garden and this time i did
discover something ralph had a secret best friend we've since moved house so and ralph's now an
indoor cat he's made the switch remarkably well and now has bella to keep him company my girlfriend's
cat although calling them friends is maybe a bit of a stretch they certainly keep each other
entertained but none of that change is the fact he's definitely keep each other entertained but
none of that change is the fact he's definitely up to something so this time so wie lautstein
das ist werbung für die kamera das ist werbung für die kamera what the fuck das ist einfach werbung
für die kamera warum ist das warum ist das nicht markiert als werbung
warum ist das video nicht markiert als werbung
du musst normalerweise wenn du den kram auf auf youtube hochlädst musst du das hekchen
setzen bei gesponsort der letzte satz ist egal du musst das video hochladen da kriegst du normalerweise
guck mal ich zeig dir das ich zeig dir das
meint ihr das ist in den usa nicht so also zum beispiel wenn ich dieses video aufmache
zack das erste was dann kommt ist includes paid promotion
und ich hätte jetzt eigentlich gedacht dass es für alle creator gilt dass man das machen muss
aber vielleicht ist es in usa nicht so
da ist gar nicht da ist gar nicht da kommt ja kommt aus uk ok
ok man sieht es ok das ist einfach eine werbung für die kardas sollte man zumindest kennzeichnen
hast du ein uk mod ne habe ich nicht ich habe nur franzosen ich habe franzosen
kekonos und kekonos
habe ich nee habe ich das ist aber sind eigentlich die australier
dass ich eigentlich australia die äußern
ok da könnte man das nicht werbung für die kamera muss nicht sein dieser titel ich habe
dieses video nur aufgemacht wegen dem titel ultra abzocke bei mediamarkt 1000 500 euro
gaming pc test ultra abzockt ist das klingt schon erst einmal in richtung die anzeige ist
raus ok ultra abzocken beim mediamarkt
4k unbedingt wichtig muss in 4k laufen mein stream ist 1080p aber video sollte 4k sein
abzock ich habe mal wieder einen krassen pc gefunden für 1450 sagen wir einfach mal grob
1500 euro und in diesen krassen pc steckt eine unkrasse krasse grafikkarte und zwar
diese das wird interessant los gehts das ist ja die huge huge massive 16k gaming grafikkarte
der heutige pc wird bei nicht von bei mediamarkt verkauft und versandt durch
sedatec von würde bedeuten mediamarkt selbst verkauft ihn bei er wird durch einen drittanbieter
verkauft aber was mediamarkt also tut das schauen wir uns jetzt mal im detail an hier haben wir
den wundervollen sedatech habe ich noch nie gehört jemand von euch schon mal je im leben was von
sedatech gehört sedatech advanced gaming pc wenn aus 10 pc desktop 9700 kf das allerneueste
ist es nicht mehr oder letzte letzte vorletzte generation vorletzte generation ist auf jeden
fall auch nicht mehr der neueste 32g ram ok mal gucken was für ein ram bestimmt kein rgb ram
bestimmt irgendwie 2000 megahertz ram oder sowas ok advanced gaming also die lautstärke
ist total unregelmäßig klingt ja schon mal noch ein krassen schnäppchen oder schaun wir uns die
bis zu 4,9 gigahertz auf einem kern 2 halb jahre alte cpu weniger liegen also schon eigentlich sehr gut aber ich finde bei diesem preis nur eine native 8 kern cpu ist schon so ein bisschen grenzwertig dazu gibt es dann 32 gigabyte ddr4
ok der schnellste speicher ist es ja nett warum erkläre ich dir gleich und die grafikkarte ist eine
unfassbar krasse ati willkommen moment moment moment was ich wollte gerade sagen das erste mal
ati aber was ist das überhaupt für eine grafikkarte sagt mir jetzt gar nichts ist so alt dass ich
mir gar nicht mehr weiß was das sein was es ist
im test von 2017 also diese vier jahre alte grafikkarte im advanced gaming pc das ja und
die war damals ja schon jetzt richtig gut ich habe meine grafikkarte ist auch 3 3 jahre
oder so die 1080 ti war damals hat richtig richtig der killer ja ja das ist irgendwie
sowas jetzt war damals schon nicht wirklich gut das ding das ist schlecht das ist ja das
ist wirklich so ein pc den man die nie omas kaufen um es dem enkel zu schenken
seit ja nicht mehr es heißt amd radian rx 550 mit verdammt krassen 2 gigabyte gddr5 video
spieler wow mind blowing krass da ja nur die grafikkarte für seedeck so günstig
verwirrt das andere geld irgendwie sinnvoll genutzt vielleicht lgb 3 t 3 t das kann ja
es die keil kann ja durchaus klargehen solide wahl warum die drei terabyte keine ahnung
dann gibt es noch ein wundervolles asus 365 ma mainboard das ist bestimmt ganz billiges
ist es das m-a ok dass das hat zumindest schon mal ordentliche ordentliche optik und sieht
nicht nach einem grünen oder braunen bord aus ohne irgendwas lga 1151 das ist ja antik
schon das ist ja uralt einen kartenleser gibt es auch noch dazu windows 10 home und hier
unten steht noch mal 450 watt netzteilen auch kundtastatur alles klar mit rgb hauptsache
lgb lg4t rgb black gehäuse mit echt lga 1151 ist bis letzte generation aktuell gewiss wirklich
es ist doch mal wie wenig ich durchblicke backtour ein hochwertiges gehäuse mit modernen
design gekuppelt mit einem leistungsstarken grafikkarte blablabla das schlimme ist die
leute glauben dass wenn die das lesen die glauben das ist eine extrem leistungsstarke
grafikkarte zeichnet diesen rechen aus der eignet sich hervorragend für kompromisslose
anwender mhm ok dieses video wird von meinem partner cdk deals unterstützt wo ihr windows
10 pro für knapp 18 euro bekommt aber mit dem eingeblendeten gut erstmal excellent
sellout 20 prozent sparen den code findet ihr in eurem cdk deals account fehler vielleicht
das war es liegt liegt das war es mehr dazu in der video beschreibung aber auch ich mache fehler
vielleicht liegt es ja an mir dass ich einfach zu viel erwarte bei diesem preis von 1500 euro
deswegen habe ich das ganze mittlerweile ist der kram so alt dass der sogar noch teurer
ist wahrscheinlich weil es kaum noch was gibt mit der 3 terabyte hd 1 terabyte m.2 ssd dazu
der koizim 9700 kf was kostet das lasst mal lasst mal raten leute was kostet das 500 euro
neu kann der liegt so auf dem level eines ryzen 5 3600 also gutes mittelfeld hier haben wir das
mainboard also es macht gute mainboards allerdings ist die plattform mit dem 1151 v2 socke schon
zwei generationen alt und wir sehen auch veröffentlicht wurde das mainboard im märz 2019 das ding ist also
über zwei jahre alt das ist ja doch noch noch 2666 megahertz langsam das liegt einfach an dem
b365 schippsatz der kann ich mehr bietet hat einfach keinerlei stützungen für arbeitsspeicher
mit und takt also über 2666 megahertz naja it is what it is dazu gibt es noch das laufwerk noch
einen internen was habe ich eigentlich für ram kann man das irgendwie unter windows nachgucken
mit welchem takt mein ram läuft bei dem mediamarkt pc das ist schon gar nicht mehr noch den cpu
killer aber ich habe aber ich habe rgb ram da ist das problem e was im task im task manager
wirklich man sieht den ram takt im task manager moment
3200 ok tatsächlich wahnsinn massif microsoft hat immer richtig nachgelegt hier kann man das
ja mal gebrauchen mein rechner ist dreieinhalb jahre alt oder so 4 4 fast vier jahre ist mein
rechner jetzt alt muss man sich mal überlegen ich glaube 2017 oder wann habe ich den wann
habe ich das video gemacht guck mal der ist vier jahre alt mein rechner und hatte besseren ram
dann habe ich hier ja das gehäuse gewählt zweimal warum weil das genannte regnum rg4t
nicht verfügbar ist aber das ventum vt 2 evo g kostet genauso viel ich bin immer noch freck
til design fan was gehäuse angeht das 430 watt netzteil windows 10 und dann kostet dieser pc
unfassbare 990 ok teurer als ich gedacht hätte selber bauen und natürlich möchte auch sedatec
etwas verdienen aber die zusammenstellung ist auch höchst beschissen oder also erstens wie
viel wie viel wie viel kostet der ram wie gesagt ich habe davon keine ahnung ich habe immer nur
ahnung davon wenn ich zusammenbauen aber die die zusammenstellung ist an sich doch beschissen also
was kostet was kostet denn der ram an sich ober kriegt man kriegt sogar noch ein kart reader was
kostet der ram hier internen kart reader weil der ist auch bei dem stehen dabei noch den cpu
kühler und dann habe ich hier ja das gehäuse gewählt zweimal warum weil das genannte regnum
rg4t nicht wo ist denn der ram mir gab es 3694 ok ne masse masse cd laufwerk weg masse kart reader
weg macht vielleicht nur 16 g ram rein meiner wegen hast du auch ein bisschen was gespart
machst auf jeden fall eine bessere grafikkarte rein vielleicht auch nicht diese plattform
sondern in aktuelle horizon plattform oder sonst was dann windows weg für was weiß ich
390 euro oder wie auch immer da kommst du wahrscheinlich deutlich bessere zusammenstellung
34 watt netzteil windows 10 und dann kostet dieser pc unfassbare 990 euro ja du musst
selber bauen und natürlich möchte auch sedatec etwas verdienen sagen wir mal eine stunde für
das ganze ding zusammenbauen und windows installieren und auf der anderen seite könnte man sagen für
den preis kriegst du nicht mal eine aktuelle grafikkarte so ist es leider aktuell ja dann ist
das aber immer noch ein echt krasser preisunterschied vielleicht ist er die nacksten 1.500 euro mit
dieser unfassbar krassen kompakten grafikkarte wirklich ihr geld wert so der i7 9700 kf wo
hat er denn jetzt her sitzt auf einem b 365 wo hat er denn jetzt ausgebildet 2666 megatz dazu die rx 550
also das was man von einem pc dieser preisklasse erwarten kann läuft hier schon mal richtig super
flüssig das war ironie mit 45 fps im durchschnitt zs mit 45 fps zs kannst du auf einer smartwatch
laufen lassen mit 300 fps übertrieben gesagt jetzt zs mit also ganz im ernst also wer zs mit
45 fps hinkriegt das ist ja das ist ein besserer taschenrechner zumal man ja auch sagen muss der
rechner an sich ist jetzt gar nicht so beschissen also mit einer ordentlichen grafikkarte würde da
viel viel mehr gehen das funktioniert natürlich so ist es rainbow 6 gut deswegen stellen wir
auf ich habe mich verguckt ich habe mich verguckt das ist nicht zs ist rainbow 6 ok das läuft
läuft ein bisschen schlecht aber trotzdem 45 habe komme ich zwischen 70 bis 80 fps was auch ja ist
ja gut es ist rainbow 6 kein zs aber zs kommt schon auch gleich noch wenn man das ganze wieder in
relation zum preis des pcs sieht es ist in schritt wahlhalle läuft gar nicht ein 200 fps reicht
nicht mal der videospeicher wollte ich gerade sagen da reicht der ram durch von der grafikkarte
und dadurch sieht es einfach auch so richtig schlecht aus und es ruckelt als fack so schlecht
oder damals ja also sollte man schon erwarten von dem 1000 euro gaming rechner die hardware an sich
die kante könnte ja viel mehr mit etwas besseren grafikkarte wie auf an xbox 360 respektive ps3
passt so gut wie bin stadia und niedriger kann ich nicht gehen läuft assassins reich
uselmeister lange für den sub habe ich nicht gesehen ganz ehrlich für weniger geld bekommst du
ein xbox series x beziehungsweise ps5 ja und darauf läuft es besser und sieht um welten besser
aus aufgrund dessen das rainbow sieht schon so gar nicht funktioniert brauchen wir uns überhaupt
keine 50 fps irgendwie co2 wowson mal zu zocken das bringt nichts deswegen kommen wir gleich zu
fortnite bei full ad und dem preset mittel und die schatten habe ich ausgeschaltet und dank dieser
sehr krassen einstellung sarcasmus läuft fortnite mit 55 fps ist so schlecht grandios gut was wir
jetzt gesehen haben und das ist schon wirklich ein paradebeispiel dafür was man aktuell und
auch auf unbestimmte zeit als pure abzocke und versagen auf allerhöchster ebene bezeichnet
versagen ist die frage stront gibt's ja welche grafikkarte irgendeine radion 5050 oder nee 550
x 550 sagen weil derjenige der das konfiguriert hat der hat wirklich seinen job verfehlt es tut
mir leid vielleicht war es auch absicht das einzige was du jetzt bekommen na moment vielleicht es
kommt auf den auftrag an wenn einer zu dem typ hingegangen ist hat gesagt hier die und die
hardware haben wir billig bekommen bau da mal was drauf ja was soll er denn sonst machen also die
sehr alt ist zwei jahre also in der technik branche geht ja viel viel schneller irgendwas ab und zwei
jahre sind da schon wieder alt und das einzige was wir dafür bekommen hast ist ein konto was das hier
macht letztendlich die die die entwicklung ist ja ein bisschen langsamer geworden also früher
gebe ich ihm voll und ganz recht da waren zwei jahre war ein pc unbrauchbar wie gesagt mein pc
ist selbst vier jahre alt das immer noch ziemlich gut mit 8700 k 1080 ti also ich kann damit problemlos
alle spielen gibt es da draußen genügend leute die ihr geld hat erarbeitet oder hat erspart
haben und wollen sich dann einen schicken pc kaufen sie sehen das bild sie haben vielleicht
nicht den plan davon und lesen so cool acht kerne ja dann dann gibt es da gibt es nur eins
er hat ja recht hat er recht aber gibt es nur eins bevor ich 1500 euro ausgebe egal für was egal
was es ist ja sei es ein neuer fernsehrechner grafikkade was auch immer ich gucke mich vorher
erst mal im internet um also bevor ich für ist es vollkommen egal was ja sollte ich mal irgendwann
mein autotunen wollen und für 1500 würde ich vorher auch im internet gucken ich würde immer
im internet vorher gucken und nie blind irgendwie drauf gucken was im mediamarkt prospect steht
da kaufe ich das was man bekommt ist aber wirklich der reinste humbug und nun könnte man haben wir
die krassen haben wir die krassen autotuner wie wie wie tunen man am besten dann opel agila 2001
ist es glaube ich von 2001 der pc wird ja verkauft und versandt durch sedatech mediamarkt trifft
er keine schuld doch mediamarkt trifft ebenfalls schuld weil du kaufst es ja bei mediamarkt das
geld geht am mediamarkt und von da aus geht es weiter an sedatech und darf es halt amazon
marketplace bei mediamarkt gelistet ist muss sedatech noch ein bisschen geld abdrücken also
es ist es ist im prinzip bisschen wie amazon marketplace wahrscheinlich mediamarkt geht das
ist dasselbe prinzip wie auf amazon das bedeutet mediamarkt als auch sedatech ziehen die hier
hart ab du bist dafür geldlos und bekommst einen pc der neu mit neuen teilen einzelnen 980 euro
wert ist allerdings und und und und und die 980 euro ja auch nur weil es eine scheiß
zusammenstellung ist gleich bekommst du für deutlich deutlich weniger und ich garantiere dir
ich stelle dir für 600 euro einen besseren pc hin dieser pc ist einfach nur auf kurzfristig
gedacht hauptsache weg damit unter der aktuellen situation möglichst viel geld machen das allerdings
menschen miteinander kommunizieren und sagen hört zu bro ich habe ein pc aber das irgendwie nicht
sogar zu bro würde ich zum beispiel nicht empfehlen bei sedatech irgendwas zu kaufen
ja kundenfeedback und zufriedenheit ist glaube ich langfristig gesehen der bessere punkt als
kurzfristig mal die marge oder den gewinn bestmöglich zu er sollte man denken sollte man denken aber
dass also das habe ich auch immer gedacht aber es gibt so viele scammer irgendwie geht das immer
weiter das scammer leben also vielleicht nicht unter sedatech aber dann nennen die sich um und
dann kennst du ich meine niemand hat was von sedatech gehört bisher und jetzt danach wird
wahrscheinlich auch keiner sagen o sedatech es ist gut ist was ganz tolles die heißen dann
halt morgen so datech oder so
think about it sedatech meine freunde damit bedanke mich fürs zuschauen ich habe jetzt
hier eine wundervolle grafikkarte über die ich übrigens auch noch gebraucht geschossen
aber hat mich 85 euro gekostet aber egal alles bzw. für die wahrheit dass keiner von euch diesen
quark pc kauft vielen dank fürs zuschauen bis neulich und ganz genau die technik nicht so
wertvoll wäre ich hätte sie jetzt einfach weggeworfen aber ich wahrscheinlich hätte
ich dann irgendwie meine geilen monitor getroffen da hätte man hätte man aber video machen könne
irgendwie irgendwie sowas wie ich zerstöre high end grafikkarte oder ich zerstöre advanced
gamer cpu gpu grafikkarte oder so kennt ihr noch die videos von früher wo die leute immer ich
zerstöre meine xbox ich zerstöre meine ps3 und so gemacht haben um noch irgendwie random clicks
abzugreifen das ist ist bisschen aus der mode gekommen aber es gab mal eine zeit haben die
leute quasi mit mit allen möglichen vom flammenwerfer bis zur presse xboxen zerstört ich schneide mit
1000 grad heiße messer durch die grafikkarte jawoll genau genau 1000 grad heißes messer versus
das war noch zeit
keine ahnung ob doch heute aber keine ahnung keine ahnung ich habe den shadow gebannt auf
youtube wir werden wahrscheinlich nie wieder von ihren von seinen kommentaren beglückt werden
zwar so lost alles einfach nur
ich ne das eddich nicht ist doof soll ich dir wieder entbannen soll ich soll ich soll ich dir
wieder entbannen dass er dass er dass er uns weiter tolle dinger schreiben kann
wahrscheinlich hat er jetzt schon zig dinger geschrieben und ich habe es wegen dem bann nicht
gesehen na gut mal gucken wie das geht dann entbanne ich den nach dem stream wieder
zur erheiterung vielleicht ist er im chat ja vielleicht ich glaube ja eh mittlerweile
dass es komplett das getrolle ist so so so durch kannst du doch eigentlich gar nicht sein wahrscheinlich
ist es vom chain oder zweite count der einfach hartkontroll action macht ok für alle die es
nicht mitgekriegt haben soll ich sage ich zeige ich zeige es noch mal mein kommentar
highlight youtube comment highlight so des letzten monats wir hatten einen in den kommentaren der
mal wieder zeigen musste was für ein geiler alpha commentator ist ich hoffe man sieht das
überhaupt jetzt wenn die leute gebannt sind ja wer sich genau angucken will
oh leute ich glaube man sieht das nicht mehr da ist er hier da ist er da ist er
er hat sich wahnsinnig über mein video aufgeregt und er möchte er möchte man muss ja muss er
hier dazu sagen er möchte eine von mir eine seriöse professionelle antwort und beginnt sein comment
mit leider doch nur ahnungsloses geschwurbel das ist natürlich die perfekte perfekte intro dass
man seriös und professionell dran darauf an darauf antwortet jaja halbes buch es wird es wird noch
lustig also wem es danach ist kann sich das ja mal durchlesen es wird noch lustig ja ich
habe dann irgendwann darauf geantwortet zu seinen punkten geschrieben dass es eigentlich überhaupt
keinen sinn ergibt und jetzt kommt und jetzt kommt das kennt das kennt ihr nicht der hat
der hat nicht das lesen wir jetzt auch nicht er hat einen halben roman geschrieben der hat
einen halben roman geschrieben aber aber zwischenzeitlich hat er sich darüber lustig
gemacht dass ich ja im monologe führe was auch irgendwie lustig ist aber mach lieber weiter
deine monologen was ich lustig finde erst mal komplette textwand gepostet hier und dann ja ja
aber reden wir weiter für dich richtig tun hat ja anscheinend hat er jetzt nächstes mal
geschrieben weil ich glaube hier drauf antworten geht immer noch auch egal ist komplett komplett
lost alter der ist wirklich durch halbe bibel ja schon dass der ist wirklich durch
ließ es bitte nee ich habe das schon gelesen aber ich muss es jetzt nicht vorlesen noch
mal im stream soll ich soll ich soll ich vorlesen wollte die richtig harten des sehen ja ok ok
weiß jetzt hallo leute hier dann muss ich jetzt erst mal suchen aber ich mein ein eins
ist eins ist schon mal gut es sorgt für content im stream deswegen sollte ich ihn eigentlich
auch wieder vielleicht kommt ja noch was also ich muss aber nicht alles vorlesen oder das
haben wir uns den letzten schon angeguckt da bin ich jetzt halbe stunde beschäftigt wenn
ich das alles noch mal vorlesen nur das neueste also wir machen wir machen die kurz wir machen
die kurzvariante also sein erstes kommen ist ich bin ein kacknup habe keine ahnung weil
irgendwelche dinger die nicht wirklich was mit dem video zu tun haben so ich habe dann
halt nicht ernsthaft darauf geantwortet das hat ihn ziemlich ziemlich aufgeregt und dann
möchte dass ich auf dieses kommend professionell antworte weil ich habe eine idee wir probieren
was aus moment leute wir probieren was aus sekunde sekunde sekunde mal gucken ob das
ob das funktioniert moment ich hoffe es kackt jetzt nicht ab test
nicht wirklich oh nein es ist gekrascht leute ich habe es gekrascht ich habe es gekrascht
das ist ich habe jeden bug drinne wo ich ja nicht genau weiß wo der herkommt ich will
das in wiebstimme haben ich will das ich will das in wiebstimme haben wie mache ich das
jetzt dass es nicht krascht wie mache ich das alles klar oder ich glaube ich glaube
er hat es verstanden alles klar ok mit diesem text to speech funktioniert es schon mal nicht
so ganz vielleicht ist japanisch text to speech englisch für deutschsprache kommets
so nicht so die beste 320 monate prime subscription ok weiter weiter im text weiter im text also
er möchte dass ich auf sein zeug hier professionell antworte da habe ich ein bisschen ja wie soll
ich sagen bisschen sinnloses zeug darauf geantwortet weil ich eigentlich gar nicht groß da diskutieren
will gerade wenn einer seine kommentare startet mit hier ist auch eh alles kacke und der beste
joke ich finde das müsste man aber auch standardmäßig als meme implement als meme hier irgendwie
etablieren m95 x fps man darf nicht vergessen selbst jemand der 1995 geboren ist ist heute
26 also es ist jetzt nicht so als wenn es irgendwelche kinder oder so egal so bla bla bla bla dann
waren richtig dann waren richtig pissed und hat schon mal hat schon mal ordentlich was
drauf geschrieben weil ich nicht ordnen weil weil ich nicht professionell und seriös darauf
geantwortet habe ich meine wir hätten nach so einem intro auch professionelles erwarten
können und dann hat er sich hier drüber aufgeregt und beendet das ganze mit das erklärt auch
warum so viele leute die grünen wählen was auch immer der zusammenhang erschließt sich
mir nicht so ganz das weiß nicht ok so dann habe ich ihm gesagt dass es keine allzu gute
idee ist so einen kommen zu schreiben und dann darauf eine seriöse professionelle antwort
zu erwarten und dass sein wissen hart nach halb halb wissen aus youtube videos klingt
und habe versucht ihm zu erklären was denn also was das problem ist ja und beziehungsweise
dass es irgendwie auch gar nichts damit zu tun hat so jetzt jetzt kommt das neueste kommt
jetzt kommt das neueste er hat wirklich er hat einen halben roman geschrieben ist wirklich
der ist komplett lost komplett durch ja der hat er hat einen halben roman geschrieben
also junge du hast gar keine ahnung du hast ja gar keine ahnung und das ganze jetzt schon
bestätigt ab alles klar ok aber danke für deinen langen kommentar das ist auch so geil
dass ich hier über das kommet lustig macht es so lange ist und da schreibe ich ein halbes
buch darunter aber danke für deinen langen kommentar ich habe mich köstlich amüsiert
und deine like fanboys leute chat das seid ihr in der chat wird gerade richtig richtig
hart gedisst hier die null ahnung von der materie zu haben scheiden sind auch wieder
likes am start ja klar man muss aber sagen gerade wenn ich hier mal in den chat kucke
wir haben unglaublich viele leute tatsächlich technisch ahnung haben ich würde fast sagen
wir haben hier auf ganz twitch den chat mit der höchsten techniker dichte also pfeif
der chat würde ich eher sagen es ist so geil prägnant und durchsichtig wie du versuchst
meine argumente zu negieren aber dabei versagst du völlig was ich auch äußerst interessant
finde dass auf die punkte die ich hier ihm nochmal verdeutlicht habe dass also erstens
der wenig zusammenhang zum video besteht und dann dass es auch wenig sinn ergibt was
er geschrieben hat darauf geht er auch gar nicht mehr ein ja darauf geht er überhaupt
nicht mehr ein ich glaube entweder und das vermute ich er ist das einfach troll comments
der sich wirklich mühe gibt oder ist hardcore triggert ich weiß ich auch komplett lost
ja ok also so durch den video versucht mein argumente zu negieren aber versags aber halt
völlig auch die deformierung ich hätte mein wissen aus youtube videos naja gut das war
jetzt eine vermutung vielleicht ist es ja noch schlimmer vielleicht glaubt er ja wirklich
da felsenfest davon überzeugt ich habe jetzt ihm eigentlich das schon nett ausgelegt mit
wissen aus youtube videos ja jetzt kommt natürlich so die die die trumpfkarte junge als ich mit
dem job angefangen habe gab es noch gar kein youtube ist das ist das quasi so die boomer
autog oder was aber ja ich weiß dass das für kiddies wie dich der heilige graal ist ich
sag nur m95 xfps mit 26 ja und finde es ach weißt du woher er das wissen kann youtube
sagt auch ich habe geburtst ne das stimmt nicht das stimmt nicht was da steht aber das
geburtst ja ist richtig von boomer zu boomer ja ok finde es auch top wie viele infos und
wissen man aus dem netz zieht und genau deshalb muss ich fehl infos wie deine eben kritisieren
jetzt ohne irgendwie auch zu erzählen er hat ja bis bis jetzt noch nicht geschafft wirklich
zu präzise konkret zu was denn eigentlich falsch ist ja leider und das sieht man auch
immer wieder auch in anderen themen sind die korrektheit der inhalte bei leuten wie dir
und deinen booby fans chatter seid wieder ihr ich finde ich finde ich finde es mittlerweile
sogar gut ich wäre gerne wieder 25 26 überhaupt kein problem nichts was man recherchieren
muss sondern nimmt es einfach so hin weil es jemand bestimmtes sagt das ist tatsächlich
was das würde ich auch kritisieren kritisieren auf youtube ja dass viele leute sachen einfach
bedingungslos glauben und hinterher das das ist schon so sowas haben wir in der politik
mit den grünen was ist die afd was das jetzt wieder damit zu tun hat verstehe ich nicht
beide seiten haben da leute die ideologisch hinterher rennen genug bestimmt aber das
hat damit so gar nichts zu tun es geht um router und exes points was hat es mit grünen
versus der afd zu tun egal wie die inhalte sind aus ideologischen gründen wird man dem
wie sie einen sagen zugejubelt und auch wenn es alle logischen fakten widerspricht wahrscheinlich
ist er auch der meinung es gibt keine klimaerwärmung oder sowas und und corona ist nur ein husten
oder sowas die jüngeren feiern das eben in dem zug finde ich es aber extrem süß wie
du dich über meine art und weiße eschow führst kann nur troll sein oder das kann nur getrollt
sein ich gehe davon langsam echt aus dass muss das ist toll kommend als youtuber der
seine kürze einfach so raushaut und dabei als einzige visuelle untermahlung an gameplay
video zeigt stimmt das stimmt dass das ist jetzt ja wirklich faktisch falsch ich zeige
ein gameplay video und ich zeige bilder und ausschnitte aus dem telekom video also ich
zeige bilder von dem gerät und ich zeige ausschnitte aus dem telekom wieder stimmt
ja gar nicht was da steht so ok jetzt kommt jetzt kommt jetzt kommt das debunking meines
videos an der stelle man wird aber sehen es hat damit wenig zu tun aber um mal auf den
inhalt einzugehen ok also daran dass du noch nicht mal die problematik von mesh access
points kennst bei der way es geht in diesem video nicht um mesh access points die telekom
box hat mesh funktionalität aber da geht es überhaupt nicht rum denn die obwohl sie
für jeden netzwerk techniker klare und eindeutige probleme mit sich bringen welche eigentlich
also man muss ja mal sagen die diese technologie an sich hat ja durch hat ja durchaus seine
daseinsberechtigung ja ja zum beispiel was weiß ich du hast ein haus erdgeschoss erster
stock und und dachgeschoss du hast eine verbindung was weiß ich dein router unten ist angeschlossen
internet technisch der in der mitte vielleicht noch per kabel und da oben plus per wireless
ablink das ist ja durchaus der existente anwendungs also in den anwendungsgebiet dass
viele leute haben und vielen leuten was was bringt also ist ja nicht so als wäre das unsinnig
das ist ja egal 3 ap ist besser als ein ja das habe ich mehr oder weniger so im video
gesagt und das ist wenn man ein ganzes haus versorgen will so wie ich im video sage auch
so wenn du ein ganzes haus versorgen willst oder eine größere wohnung aber geh mal vom
ganzen haus ich glaube das nehme ich auch als beispiel sind da ist ein access point auch
wenn das ein super high hand 400 euro access point ist höchstwahrscheinlich deutlich zu
wenig dass du auch noch empfang auf der terrasse hast das ist mein beispiel beispiel im video
und ja selbstverständlich ist es besser zeigt mir klar aber das ist nicht so aber das ist
anscheinend nicht so zeigt mir klar dass du noch nie ein firmen ap netzwerk mit mehreren
teilnehmern das hat damit doch überhaupt gar nichts zu tun das ist einfach randomness
pur und ja auch in der firma ist das so ich meine außer es ist okay vielleicht ist das
in seiner ein mann klitsche so dass sie alle in einem büro sitzen dann reicht auch ein
access point um einen wegen aber gerade wenn er doch super vielleicht hatte wir hatten
doch wir hatten doch gestern abend einem im chat der probleme mit dem wlan im altersheim
hatte vielleicht hatte er vielleicht hat er ja das wlan im altersheim da eingerichtet
keine ahnung aber selbstverständlich ist das in der firma auch so dass du in fast jedem
büro oder zumindest mal je nach infrastruktur und größe mindestens mal in jeder in jedem
stockwerk einen access point hast aber eigentlich in jedem großraumbüro unter der decke was
okay jetzt jetzt kommen halt sachen die problematisch sind die aber auch absolut gar nichts mit
der sache zu tun haben frequenz überlagung signal ob die sind sie scheinbar überhaupt
keinen begriff hat damit auch gar nichts zu tun du musst dir keine keine gedanken machen
über frequenz überlagung sicher wenn du einen access point irgendwo hier stellt und
dann auf der terrasse keine empfang hast wenn du dann einen zweiten access point hinstellt
dass du empfangen hast dann ist es definitiv besser als einer wo ist dann das problem dabei
so jetzt und jetzt ok das war übrigens alles um die sache zu debanken der letzte der rest
ist wieder richtig krasser rent und und zeugt auch von ziemlich unwissenheit so das ist
das ist das best jetzt das ist als würde ich mich als schiffs captain über untiefen
und wetterlagen mit einem kleinkind unterhalten dass gerade seinen geliebten gummi ente in
der badewanne spielt wahrscheinlich ist es sinnvoller sich damit dem kleinkind drüber
zu unterhalten als mit ihm gehe ich auch von aus auch die fehlerparameter von speedtests
an endgeräten versuchst du damit zu entmachten dass es gängige praxis ist will er wirklich
sagen dass ein speedtest den man über einen router mit irgendwie von der telekom firmen
integrierten speed dass du damit genauer mist als mit einem endgerät mit der passenden
software und auf der das entbehrt jeglicher praxis jeglicher logik und auch jegliche erfahrung
also so und jetzt kommt die entgegen kann es ja nicht richtig entkräften er sagt jetzt
einfach nur weil ich gesagt habe es ist gängige praxis dass vieles was schwachsinn ist gängige
praxis ist genau diese argumentation ist das was ich beanstaltet sie hat nichts mit den
inhalten zu tun bei the way ihr müsst mal lesen was ich geschrieben habe das stimmt
überhaupt nicht dass ich ich habe gesagt speedtest bandbreiten performance test endgeräte
ist gängige praxis und wenn man das wirklich ganz genau messen testen will dann geht das
sogar nur von einem endgerät aus mit passender software und wenn man genau messen will dann
ist das so wenn du wirklich genau messen willst dann nimmst du dir eine gegen dann nimmst
du ein netzwerkgerät stöpselst auf der einen seite eine kiste dran auf der anderen seite
eine rechner dran machst dann was weiß ich von alperf bis sonst was mit den passenden
parametern dass du genau testen kannst okay wie verhält sich das mit tcp traffic wie
fällt es das mit udp traffic wie ist das mit dieser paketgröße wie ist das wenn ich zu
große sachen schicke wie auch immer das machst du nun mal von endgeräten aus so jetzt jetzt
das argument ist wenn man wenn in einem brennenhaus aus panik zehn leute vom dach in den tot
stürzen um nicht in den flammen umzukommen jetzt jetzt kommt zwei wird zweiter weit her
geholt ist das eine gängige praxis bringt also nix ja nur mit oh nein nein es wird nur
mit dem unterschied dass das was ich geschrieben habe nicht nur gängige praxis ist sondern
auch so wirklich gut funktioniert wird das nice ja leute ich wollte es nicht vorlesen
ihr wolltet unbedingt sehen ob es was neues gibt okay weiss ich nicht ob er das entdeckt
hat so okay geht weiter so und jetzt und jetzt kommt jetzt kommt big brain halbwissen in
person eigentlich müsste ich ein video machen ich werde gedisst von zuschauer das ich brauche
einen besseren ich brauche einen viel besseren titel so videos gehen immer so videos so videos
gehen eigentlich immer das ist richtig muss ich aufschreiben das ist das ist das ist gut
guter content okay aber das geilste ist dass vpn nix mit routern zu tun hat das ist bei
the way überhaupt nicht das was ich gesagt habe ich habe gesagt dass routing und vpn
zwei unterschiedliche funktionalitäten sind und mein argument ist finde ich relativ einleuchtend
wenn das beides und respa miteinander das ist ein geiler titel netzwerkexperte nimmt
mich hops krass das mache ich das ist das ist das ist super titel perfekt das ist richtig
guter titel ich sage auch hier das sieht man alleine schon daran dass es schon router lange
vor vpn gab wo man eigentlich erkennen sollte ok routing an sich und vpn vpn sind unterschiedliche
funktionalitäten warum er jetzt mit nat um die ecke kommt habe ich keine ahnung nat
hat mit routing auch nur so am rande was zu tun nat ist dafür geschaffen worden um mit
begrenztem ipv6 adressen vorrat klarzukommen das ist so so nach dem motto man kann nichts
dagegen sagen man schreibt einfach fünf andere sachen dabei die damit der eigentlichen thematik
gar nichts zu tun hat was vpn mit nat zu tun hat ja nix auch nix du hast mit nat manchmal
probleme mit vpn wenn du vpn über nat versucht aber ansonsten keine ahnung das hat nichts
miteinander zu tun kein kein schimmer das hat also ich habe kein schimmer was was was
uns das sagen soll das hat nichts nie also mit der ursprung thematik schon mal gar nichts
und auch dass der zusammenhang macht wieder überhaupt keinen sinn genau das ist erstreut
zur verwirrung random sachen ein die einfach ja random sind und jetzt kommt sein big brain
seiten hieb und des seiten hiebs mit den fünf gigabit hast du immer noch nicht verstanden
jeder seiten hieb ist einfach so unglaublich schwierig und kompliziert zu verstehen dass
es wahrscheinlich auch nur für ihn sinn ergibt ich habe deine kernaussagen gerade mal einem
kollegen das ist natürlich immer das beste argument ja wenn ich sage du hast keine ahnung
in ich kenne noch jemand der sagt auch du hast keine ahnung das ist natürlich überzeugend
überzeugung pur ja ich habe deine kernaussage gerade mal einem kollegen vorgelesen wir haben
uns beide auf anhieb köstlich amüsiert dann also danke ich dachte heute wieder auf grund
des wetters war laune gerettet ich würde mich ja mit dir gerne mal live live meint
er im real life unterhalten bringt er dann auch seinen kollegen mit oder oder wie ist
das um zu sehen wie du einfach nach den ersten zehn minuten nach luft das ist das anzeige
wollen die mich wollen mich verprügeln oder oder was ist hier los man ks vom heck vom
heckermann zum schläger alter ok das ist das ist das geilste das ist jetzt wirklich das ist
das ist jetzt das allergeilste aber mach lieber weiter deine monologe hallo guckt euch das
kommet an what the fuck also wenn hier einer den monolog hält dann ja wohl er so ok der
chat chat wird angefeindet hier aber lernt mal mit kritik und leuten um den du nicht
das was erreichen das ist so krass realitätsfern das ganze zeug ist der wahnsinn oh man komplett
los ja was anderes ist mir fällt mir da echt nicht mehr dazu ist schon geil oder scheiße
was trinken ok meine güte das aber echt eine gute idee netzwerk experte nimmt mich hops
das finde ich das finde ich gut da muss ich echt ein video zu machen oder am besten noch
fünf ausrufe zeichen oder sowas hinten dran ich weiß nicht was ich kann schlecht einschätzen
am anfang habe ich gedacht es ist reines trolling ich glaube es immer noch ich glaube das einfach
einer der es wirklich drauf anlegt und möglichst gut tarnen will oder der es einfach wirklich
nur total abgefuckt aus irgendwelchen gründen also schon wirklich ja m 95 x fbs exposed ja
zwei buber im thumbnail ja wahrscheinlich was was hat er geschrieben als ich angefangen
habe gab es noch kein google oder sowas nee was hat er geschrieben als ich angefangen
habe gab es noch kein internet der ist noch mehr boomer als youtube der ist glaube ich
noch mehr boomer als ich wobei als ich angefangen habe gab es auch noch seit wann gibt es youtube
2005 2005 ja nee das stimmt als ich angefangen habe gab es auch noch kein youtube tatsächlich
wobei das jetzt nicht unbedingt für ihn spricht ne also das wird ja mit eurer g null mit der
zeit youtube videos sind eine super informationsquelle heutzutage ich würde sogar sagen gerade wenn
es um programmier sprachen und technologie geht sich mal ein youtube tutorial anzugucken
ist oftmals besser als irgendwelche komischen getting started seiten zu anzugucken also
weiß nicht wo also wo das wo das problem mit youtube videos ist wie dem auch sei so chat
konnt ihr jetzt eine runde runde kecken jetzt gucken wir so irgendwas anderes sinnvolles
an wir gucken uns jetzt die besten battlefield 3 infanterie clips an der schlamm pc ist ripp
das habe ich gesehen ok weil es weil es es ist nicht der cute mod aber es ist der poggers
mod der sich wünscht dass wir dieses video gucken aber das habe ich glaube ich schon
gesehen ich fand es nicht sonderlich sonderlich spannend außer dass das mainboard nee das
ist gar nicht das was ich meine ich habe der hatte doch irgendwie mal den hochwasser pc
ach doch das ist das doch oder nee hat er nicht ein anderes mit dem hochwasser pc das
ist ein anderes ach das ist die grafikkarte wo wir letzte woche geguckt haben die sauber
gemacht hat oder es ist ein anderer ja aber ich glaube das ist nicht sonderlich spannend
jetzt als follow-up will es jetzt noch mal runde über teile wir gucken jetzt runde battlefield
3 erstmal die webseite renten warum wir gucken jetzt runde battlefield 3 gab ewig kein top
play video mehr was sonst natürlich metro shotgun selbstverständlich welche clip denn
sonst lassen sich wieder weg klatschen er in your face 90 japan aber es ist von der
leute sind einfach zu 3 hat 3 hat das ist schon geil die posis sind eher auf bazaar
die spawnen ja auch dahin in der eck wenn sie die fahne haben die spawnen da ja auch
drin und wenn du pech hast spawnen sie auch hinter dir ja er wieder was ist das für eine
waffe die des china ding china chinesen waffe gekommodert waffe ja jetzt ist halt so preschen
jetzt triffst du mit so press nichts oh das war lucky richtig lag wie es der name wie
es der name sagt dass er dabei so preschen so gut reingehauen hat noch das ist aber wieder
wegschneiden ja bämer noch mal den ausgabe jawoll in this next clip abina takes out to
meines lieblings waffe in dem game das gameplay hätte man im ticken heller machen können
dass man aber sieht vor allem das gameplay ist mega bass boosted oder bass boosted und
ziemlich rechts auf der rechten seite ab ist bei euch auch so ihr hört fast nur was
rechts und dann ultra bass lastig ich mag dass das bewegungen während dem schießen
nichts ausmacht ich finde das nice wenn man mit wasd und und und movement ein bisschen
sein ppega aim korrigieren kann jetzt halt wieder so volle suppression drin triffst
wieder gar nichts wie es wieder rennt nach reflex ab das gesehe
in this one i suppose it is infantry but a long range rpg that was just too good not to
see in this clip is so good i love watching every second gut m16 sprayt ein leute die
vorsicht sind glaubt es kriegen die meisten im chat auch noch gebacken und der war cool
ja das muss man aber zu gut halten also der der magnum headshot hier flick auf den
kopf das war schon nicht ohne war ein bisschen ein bisschen glück das getroffen aber schon
cool ist das eine auk die eitgenossen sind am start hier oberweil ne auk war ne schweizer
oder oder österreicher ich kann es mir immer nicht merken der chat weiß das bestimmt österreicher
aber noch nicht die schweizer ok österreicher das ist schon nice also die head die mag
headshots ist nicht ohne sk 553 ist schweizer ja leider hat die ziemlich gesagt in dem game
ich hasse diese posi alter ich hasse diese posi
ja g36 auch nicht so der wahnsinn diese posi ich hasse sie weil du kannst den tdm ja auch
nichts machen mit anderen kann sie da hoch fliegen und gerade in rush ist die posi ziemlich
sinnlos 50 prozent der clips für tdm loscher ja ist so metro bazaar loscher fertig was andere
spielen die leute irgendwie nicht mehr deswegen fand ich das in wenn es richtig cool dass
die leute mal wieder moment moment wir machen wir machen mal den den wöchentlichen wenn
es check was meint ihr was ist der server mit den höchsten spielerzahlen also ich tippe
auf acht spieler acht spieler
sechs spieler es ist so dead alter es ist so dead hast du schon mal splitgate gespielt
nein aber ich habe schon auf twitter von vielen leuten gelesen dass das richtig richtig nice
sein muss mit bots ich werde ich bettel viel spiele mich gegen bots spielen
alter die lassen sich wieder wegspringen ja ja ja ja ja das sind so die typischen kennt
ihr diese sniper die nur durch ihr scope gucken können in eine richtung die gesamte runde
die kriegen nichts mit von der welt um sie man sieht bei guten snipern egal in welchem
game dass sie nicht hartscope den ganzen tag in eine richtung sondern dass die immer wieder
gucken zwischendurch posi wechseln piken da hier gucken da um die ecke da mal kurz fünf
sekunden halten dann wieder um die ecke piken also gute sniper sind immer zwar vielleicht
in dem gebiet aber sind immer in bewegung kaknup sniper sitzen in eine richtung gucken
durch der scope und gucken in die gleiche gleiche ecke
p90 das stimmt ja das ding ist progas zwar ich dachte es verkippt apg headshot
was sind das für server ich würde die runden auch gerne mal haben na gut das ist halt bettel
viel du kannst den bettel viel auch eine runde haben die nicht das mal kurz jetzt gucken du
kannst den bettel viel auch eine runde haben die nicht gut läuft und zwischenzeitlich
richtig krassen plays raushauen aber in der regel ist natürlich so die leute konstant
gute plays raushauen die sind auch immer oben zeigt mir das scoreboard please
wo ist er denn wahrscheinlich gerade ist gejohnt also bettel viel 22 42 vorbestellt nicht sehe
ich auch nicht ein
jetzt kommt bestimmt wieder ane okay macht er macht roadkill ich dachte es kommen wieder
irgendwelche smoke smoke kills der hat wenigstens immer ein bisschen was ausgefallenes
okay die gegner sind wieder komplett komplett brain dat rätts immunität
ok die werden hardcore zerstört gerade die kriegen die kriegen richtig richtig massiv
auf den sack die clips von ihm gucke ich mir immer gerne
an das ist ja wenigstens bisschen was ausgefallen ist am am coolsten sind immer die clips die
radar manchmal hat mit rauchgranaten rauchgrad irgendwie 5 6 7 8 kills mit rauchgranaten in
folge metro ich wette mit euch ich weiß nicht wie man das ausspricht aber entspricht man
spricht es bestimmt nicht aus man spricht das bespricht das irgendwie russisch garantiert
anders aus das gucken wir jetzt mal moment das müssen wir jetzt mal überprüfen moment
wie gibt es in russischen text zu speech gibt es in russischen auf russisch ok zeig
her how to pronounce ok bitch nick bitch nick bitch nick so ähnlich bitch nick bitch
nick alles klar war klar dass man das nicht pech neck ausspricht oder so was wie ich
oder den typ sagen würde behind enemy players you watch the kills just rack up so quickly
weiter weiter ich muss ich muss noch mal kurz miss kann ich habe die die beste die beste
gelegenheit des streams verpasst wir waren mal 95 ich muss ich muss kann noch mal kurz
back zu dem anderen clip ich habe ich habe die beste gelegenheit ist so das muss jetzt
noch mal sein mit dem passenden overlay jetzt ist der clip gleich viel besser noch besser
ok jetzt können wir wieder zurück da wenn sie wieder wegsprayt
die sind wieder komplett komplett lost einfach die gegner wenn ich wenn sie nicht aber das
ist aber auch und also man muss auch sagen hier noch hier noch den überblick zu behalten
wenn man also in spawn gedrückt wird und vor allem noch motiviert zu bleiben ist auch schwierig
back rage damit damit der beck gerätscht bis zum geht nicht mehr
boah alter wie kann man nicht checken dass da im gang grad was abgeht rätst ja wohl
die users aber das war ein geiler klipp
das stick with this theme of metro run and gun clips we've got poets md coming in with
42 is alive service there is a chance for more maps i think coming in the future
is the rex beste
bett die die alten battlefield friends die waren cool ja
boah ist aber warum killt ihn dann keiner
die gekommenen zwitter hier am start
warum killt ihn keiner da steht er da steht er mit der pistole fünf minuten zwischen
die gegner drum alter
die trainung dankeschön dass so ach so ich habe gerade was subscribt wie was hier aber
schön dass du den weg gefunden hast
erstens gefunden da ich habe hast du empfehlung bekommen in twitch welche welche kanäle
man angucken soll oder hast du kommen video beschreibung gesehen weil ich habe jetzt auch
schon viele leute hier wieder getroffen im chat die gesagt haben ich hatte sie hatten
keine ahnung dass ich stream aber twitch hat den stream vorgeschlagen auf youtube videos
ok
was sonst
das ist ja mal richtig old school jemand damit was ist das denn ich split mit auferlehrer
das verwendet wirklich noch jemand ich split
ich split war so ganz ganz ganz am anfang von live streams
er läuft dann durch die metro also so clips habe ich vielleicht soll ich den kram wirklich
mal einschicke ich meine so clips habe ich auch einige wo ich durch die metrohäuser
stelze und da alle alle paar sekunden mal also
davon habe ich jetzt auch einige clips ich laufe durch die metrohäuser und kill leute
auf der straße
durch den smog mokka smog
oh nice
thanks for watching this episode of the battlefield 3 top plays if you've got any clips that
you want
das ist halt die sache gewesen du kannst in battlefield in battlefield 3 mit der richtigen
posi und ähm so dem richtigen game sense auch jetzt ohne der ultra krasse aimer zu sein
richtig krass abgehen weil hier ist jetzt nichts irgendwie ultra high skilliges mechanic
technisch dabei gewesen was wir da gesehen haben
er hatte die richtige position zur richtigen zeit und das richtige timing weil da jetzt
jetzt
gaming stream es gibt ja leider nichts was ich streben was ich streben kann gaming technisch
wir können höchstmal wieder battlefield 3 spielen bf2042 wenn es dann taugt werden
wir uns paar mal on stream geben
achja es ist ja ergeblich jetzt irgendwie auch playtest bald aber ich wurde nicht eingeladen
also pepehands aber mal davon abgesehen ging eh nur mit nda und nicht nicht stream
was was was gucken wir denn jetzt noch secret windows folders
ich wollte mir das w das das new world beta fazit noch angucken weil ich wissen will
was andere leute zu sagen ich habe ja nur wald lustigerweise ich habe ja auch
ein erster eindruck video gemacht da mich die leute übrigens auch ein bisschen bisschen
ausgelöst wieder so nach dem motto spiel doch erst mal eine weile bevor du ein review
machst oder ein fazit siehst sieht das hier in irgendeiner art und weise nach einem review
oder nach einem fazit aus ich erzähle am anfang ich bin level 12 und erzähle jetzt
meine eindrücke meine güde er nicht gesehen so und da waren wir ganz viele ganz der ist
auch ein erbärmlicher zeitvertreib ja man hätte schreiben können mmos sind nicht meins
oder aus dem mmo alter bin ich raus oder was auch immer aber nein erbärmlich alter erbärmlich
nicht irgendwie finde ich nicht toll finde ich nicht gut was erbärmlicher zeit vertreibt
die leute wer ist jetzt die neue copypasta hier
ist eh auch geil in ich habe das video geskippt als du meintest der dark age of cannot werden
das beste pvp mmo sorry aber spiel erst mal pleite das ich meine erstens vor stories serious
serious ja vor stories also na gut und bleck deshalb habe ich gespielt bleck deshalb hat
coole pvp ansätze aber man kann das null mit dark age of cannot vergleichen bleck deshalb
ist open world pvp was immer weiter genervt wurde weil du mittlerweile ok ich weiß ich
habe jetzt ich habe jetzt schon über ein jahr nicht mehr gespielt aber wenn du in bdo
ernsthaft open open world pvp machen wolltest dann hast du instant dein gear geschrottet
und wurde sonst wie negativ gekamert sonst was es sei denn du warst in der großen gilde
und konntest irgendwie eine andere gilde bekriegen ja also open world pvp wurde immer weiter
genervt soweit ich das mitbekommen habe also immer weniger attraktiv gemacht und es gab
halt ab und zu noch irgendwelche gebiet schlachten das hat aber null so cool das sein mag das
hatte null mit dem pvp konzept von da zu tun da war das beste pvp da da stehe ich dazu
da bleibe ich auch bei das beste pvp es hat ja nicht umsonst den pvp diesen diesen award
für das beste beste pvp game of the decade gewonnen was hältst du von guild wars 2 pvp
das ist tatsächlich relativ inspiriert davon und das elder scrolls online pvp mit den fraktionen
ist auch relativ da auch inspiriert aber ich habe guild wars 2 nicht viel gespielt an pvp
das einzige was ich gesehen habe pvp dass man in dieser einen map immer im kreis gerannt
ist und sich regelmäßig gebashed hat das war nicht so der wahnsinn aber da ist ist
und bleibt das beste pvp mmo die kombination aus grenzgebiete mit festungen zum einnehmen
und wirklich impact des pvp ist auf das restliche spiel aber nicht zu viel dass auch pvm leute
spielen können wir einfach absolut geniales konzept und ich kann es bis heute nicht verstehen
warum es da keine mal sinnvolle neuauflage von gibt und schenkt kannst du knicken ja
und schenkt ist was ist das es ist nicht dead on arrival es ist dead before arrival kam
a lot und schenkt das wird nie rauskommen ja runescape jetzt hört mal auf jetzt werden
die dinge ausgebottelt für die leute die ja noch noch mehr boomer hardcore kleiner sind
als ich aber runescape ist sicherlich auch cool für alle die gerne den ganzen tag irgendwelche
crafting materialien und und exen killen so das ist das einzige was ich mal gesehen habe
von runescape war ein stream von einem der hat fünf stunden irgendwelche low level exen
gekillt dass er crafting materialien oder so bekommt da habe ich mir auch gedacht was
zum teufel ist das hier eigentlich was das geht ihr ab aber ich habe von runescape keine
ahnung will ich mir auch nicht geben ja so also mich interessiert man auf was andere
leute noch zu new world sagen ich habe nicht mal so großartig weiter gespielt glaube bis
level war ich am ende ich war nicht level 20 ich war irgendwie 18 oder so dann ist mir
das im kreis quest borde irgendwie zu langweilig geworden aber gucken was er sagt mal gucken
was er sagt vielleicht das gibten wir auch ein bisschen was so vom namen her glaube
ich war da sogar in diesem deutschen deutschen fraktions turnier was es da gab oft auf diesem
einen surfer mit dabei was ja was ich gelesen habe aber ich spiele das video mal ab aber
was ich gelesen habe was die deutschen ja hardcore verloren haben was mich aber auch
nicht wundert die deutschland ist ein land der casual let's play noobs die keine ahnung
von nix haben keine spiele gescheit spielen können ich meine damit beide ich meine nicht
ihn ich mein generell ihn kenne ich nicht kann ich nichts zu sagen und ich nehme ihn
da jetzt explizit voraus ja aber in der regel so im durchschnitt hast du da so viele casual
let's play noobs in deutschland am start es ist der wahnsinn die kriegen nix die können
nix gescheit spielen das sage ich als 37 jährige boomer da auch nicht mehr gut ist
video soll es wie der name schon sagt um ein fazit zum bettel vor new world gehen darüber
hinaus auch mein generellen eindruck von close beta sowie die pläne zum release das hat
schon mal nice nice bass in der stimme fangen wir mal mit dem bettel an vom 20 juli bis
schön schön kompressor eingeschaltet close beta von new world start das am 31 august dann
vollständig releasing soll wenn es aber bleibt laut genug darüber hinaus auch eben dieses
bettel von new world für diejenigen die es verpasst haben ist das ist das donkey kong
musik im hintergrund zurückblick das war ein wettstreit zwischen einem französischen
einem englischen und einem deutschen team beziehungsweise deren fraktion syndicates
marauders und covenant ich durfte als einer von elf für das deutsche team antreten und
entenburg da ist er das ist er doch oder stimmt und was ich auch gelesen habe ist kronk hat
voll mega gesagt ich habe nicht geguckt ich habe nur auf reddit bisschen reddit ja reddit
bisschen bisschen gelesen was da so abgeht kong muss wohl übelst gesagt haben in dem
game weiß ich ob sie jemand von euch gefolgt hat ob das ob das so ist ja habe ich habe
ich gelesen vorweg zu sagen aber gut so muss man zu guter kong ist glaube ich noch eine
runde mehr boomer als ich ich glaube da ist sogar noch ein paar jahre älter das den genadenlos
verloren die gründe für die scheinende punkte ohrfeige sind vielfältig also ja wir hatten
was kong hatte zwischendurch ein kleines oh echt wirklich ist er ist er im blut im
flutgebiet das wusste ich nicht ja dann ist kein wunder dann ist dann hätte ich wirklich
auch andere sorgen also wenn man keller absäuft hätte ich auch andere sorgen als über zu
spielen aber du siehst halt hier schon mal guck mal du siehst hier schon mal die ersten
dass die gescheite leute haben das sind jetzt wie gesagt ich kenne auch nur die namen so
vom vom vom zu drüber scrollen aber du siehst schon mal wen die wen die anderen haben ok
die sagen wir nicht alpha kast kenne ich aber ansonsten also ja wir hatten weniger aktive
spieler in unserer gruppe und gerade unsere kommunikation war ok wen haben wir denn wen
haben wir beim deutschen team dabei wo ich sage da könnte ein o-tech nicht gut was reißen
ja ihn kenne ich nicht aber er ist er ist vorne habe ich auch noch am rande kenne ich
war vom namen er sagt mir nix
ich kenne ich kenne die meisten vom namen habe ich mal gehört aber ich maße mir das
nicht an einschätzen zu können ob das ob das die krassen mmo oder sind keine ahnung
sagen wir mal durchaus ausbaufähig aber darüber hinaus gab es auch eine ganze reihe von anderen
faktoren die sich für uns negativ ausgewirkt haben wir wussten zum beispiel nicht im gegensatz
zu den franzosen die das extrem früh wussten dass das taunenbord das ist so ein schwarzes
brett in der stadt über das man missionen annehmen kann damit man dann die stadt eben
ausbessern kann eine bessere schmiede haben kann und so weiter dass das so eine unfassbar
gute quelle für erfahrungspunkt ich hatte zwar so gewinnst du aber gerade bei mmos knowledge
theorie crafting also du gewinnst du gewinnst sachen world first geschichten in mmos gewinnst
du nicht durch krassen krasses aim und mechanics du brauchst knowledge über das game wie kein
zweiter und du musst theorie craften am besten drei wochen bevor das game rauskommt und jedes
noch so abgedrehte alpha feature die angucken ob man das nicht irgendwie abusen kann so gewinnt
zu mmo geschichten die alpha schon sehr intensiv gespielt aber da niemals über diese art so viel
gelevelt sondern halt einfach ein bisschen quest gemacht waffen ausprobiert die welt erkundet und
so weiter das heißt das war ein riesen riesen riesen riesen startvorteil für die insbesondere
die franzosen und es gab eben deutlich mehr als jede andere aktivität und gerade wenn man dann
die community hatte als streamer die dir alles in den allerwertesten geschoben hat dann war das
ein ganz ganz ganz krasser boost im levelbereich als wir das dann rausgefunden hatten kam kurz
darauf ein sehr krasser nerf und wir konnten den vorteil nicht mehr so richtig mitnehmen
und durch diesen gewaltigen levelvorsprung was dann auch sehr leicht an anderen fronten mehr
punkte zu machen zum beispiel man hat ja sehr viele punkte bekommen durch die kriege durch sowas wie
invasions wenn man da teil dran genommen hat da muss man level 50 für sein durch dungeons und so
weiter das soll aber alles keine ausrede für das erbärmliche deutsche doch keine cheater die haben
game mechanics genutzt die drin waren so gewinnst du in mmos indem du die sachen besser verstehst
besser weiß knowledge ist king in mmos also game game game knowledge und und wissen wieder spiel
funktionieren ist das was sich in mmos gut macht also game game knowledge und und durchblick wieder
spiel funktioniert ist im endeffekt der mmos gilt schlechthin im vergleich zu was weiß ich aiming
bei shootern ja abschneiden sein denn wir haben halt zu recht auch in der höhe verloren auch wenn
das jetzt klingt wie eine fußballpresse konferenz also von daher das war halt wirklich keine besonders
gute performance mal klar sagen es hat aber trotzdem mega viel spaß gemacht warum da komme ich
gleich noch zu ich konnte wenigstens mein persönliches ziel erreichen und der erste meiner
gruppe werden also der deutschen gruppe unter der leitung von gronkh sie wäre schon noch mit
dem gewesen aber immer mehr von ihm gebraucht die hätten mehr von ihm gebraucht dann hätten sie
chance gehabt dieses kleine persönliche ziel konnte konnte da erreicht werden es wird aber
trotzdem zum release bei allen teilnehmern des events einen besonderen drop geben auf twitch
also auf jeden fall zum release selbstverständlich wenn man das ganze massiv stream auf twitch.tv
endenburg oder bei den kollegen die da mitgemacht haben also bei meinen deutschen kollegen gerne
reinschauen denn wie gesagt da wird da wird es dann besondere belohnungen geben die damit einher
gehen mit diesem mit der teilnahme an diesem event ich möchte jetzt aber vor allen dingen ein paar
eindrücke zur beta insgesamt also nützt ja weil das war ja so das spannendste zu sehen wo steht
denn das spiel jetzt was funktioniert gut was funktioniert nicht so gut da bin ich mal gespannt
also ich war ja skeptisch was da was da inhalten drin sind und ich habe jetzt so zwei ich habe
das ja ich habe wie gesagt ich habe nicht nicht wahnsinnig weit gespielt aber ich habe das die
ganze beta über verfolgt was ich auch fragwürdig fand dass am letzten beta tag glaube ich der
letzte der letzte boss schon geklärt wurde mit max level natürlich und ziemlich gut im gier nach
zwei wochen beta endenburg spiel ausschließlich ja so welche so leute brauchst du um so ein
wettbewerb zu gewinnen die wissen wie immer muss funktionieren und was wollte ich jetzt sagen ja
ich habe ich habe ich habe so zwei zwei zwei verschiedene zwei verschiedene fraktionen es
gibt eigentlich bei new world so geteilt es gibt leute die sagen irgendwie überhaupt nichts für
mich und es gibt welche die feiern das game von ich habe ich habe ganz wenig gesehen so nach dem
motto ja ich werde es mir mal angucken paar monate spielen dann wahrscheinlich aufhören also viele
haben es übelst gefeiert und viele haben aber auch gleich gesagt ist überhaupt nicht das game für
mich das ist bei mmos finde ich selten so weil mmos gerade auch darauf setzen dass du eben diese
diese für alle also viele mmos versuchen ja so für alle ein bisschen was und möglichst so den
cry ein bisschen ausrollen so mit nudelholz so über die dauer hinweg dass jeder so ein bisschen
was hat ein bisschen vor sich hin questen kann und sonst wie und da bin ich da bin ich echt mal
gespannt ja ich habe immer noch meine bedenken dass sie auf zu vielen hochzeiten tanzen wollen
und ich finde es auch ein bisschen merkwürdig dass sie sagen wir machen pvp open world pvp aber
es ist quasi die gleichen gebiete für alles aber man kann sich flaggen und so das erscheint mir
wie man möchte beides einbauen aber sich nichts zu was richtigen committen vielleicht liege ich
auch falsch vielleicht ist es später komplett anders und ich bin mal gespannt wie amazon das
händelt was da was da rauskommt weil inhalt technisch scheint das doch ein bisschen mau zu
sein mal gucken und darüber wie gesagt ich hätte kein problem wenn es wieder ein weiteres geiles
mmo kann ich schon mal sagen ich hatte eine insane gute zeit und werde die pause zwischen jetzt der
beta so dem 3 august und dem release 31 verbringen wie so ein nicotine kaugummi kaunder zigaretten
süchtling denn ich werde diese welt wirklich wirklich wirklich vermissen new world ist ein
besonderes mmo so in vielerlei hinsicht ich will jetzt nicht alles vorweg nehmen denn es wird
entweder kurz vor oder kurz nach release auch noch ein zehn minuten video geben okay das klassische
klassische video auf die video format auf dem hauptkanal wo ich dann sehr viel über und auch
sehr strukturiert über das mmo sprechen werde aber ich wollte gerne mal ein paar aspekte quasi
jetzt hier so eine art podcast formfass schon ansprechen die für die bete halt wichtig
gewesen sind und die deshalb jetzt schon mal genannt werden müssen auch wenn sie ein stück
weit das zehn minuten video vorweg nehmen new world ist in gewissen sehr zentralen
bereichen struktur die haben irgendwie nur fünf gegnertypen bei den normalen monstern
ein old school ja ich weiß es gibt noch mehr aber es ist halt es ist es sind halt mehr oder
weniger die recycelt animationen recycelte dinger ja da hast du hast vielleicht nicht
fünf sondern hast 20 aber das ist trotzdem nicht viel plus die bosse also das fiel das
ist auch so ein und ich hatte es ist viel es fehlt irgendwie ein bisschen an vielfalt mit
gemeint in new world spielt das soziale eine große eine billion angeschön hier aber nicht
mehr schieber bei dem es nicht nur darum geht dieses so schnell wie möglich hinter sich zu
bringen um dann den endgame teil zu erreichen in dem man dann endlich spaß haben darf mit
dem spiel ja das finde ich auch der schwierigkeitsgrad ist schon in der level phase mitunter richtig
richtig knackig das heißt wir haben wie gesagt noch mal das soziale ja das ist so genau richtig
das siehst du an den quests und ich finde daran sieht man das game wollte ursprünglich voll
auf pvp comitten hat dann aber gesagt ah das ist zu niche wir machen jetzt noch pvm deswegen
wirkt das auch so so halbherzig das pf die ganze pvm geschichte was eine riesenrolle spielt ein
relevantes early und mid game und kraftig und pvp wollten sie ja schon immer machen zum beispiel
auch auf classic w o w zu nur dass new world eben kein high fantasy tepp-target theme park
mmos wie es mittlerweile eine hunderte davon gibt sondern eine komplett neue gut dafür hat
world of warcraft gerade classic noch so was wie eine story was new world ja ich wirklich
hatten erfahrung da ist dann der zweite teil also strukturell ist new world ein fast schon
old school mmo das stimmt auf der anderen seite auch ein komplett neues mmo und fast schon das
moderne mmo wenn man so will also weil man sowas eben noch nicht gesehen hat also die welt fühlt
sich an wie eine mischung aus also ich würde mal zippen ich würde ich würde mal sagen eine
mischung aus gothic mit ein bisschen skyrim drin bisschen witcher drin vielleicht sogar und die
welt fühlt insgesamt sich insgesamt faschon ein bisschen an wie so eine singleplayer rollenspielwelt
was gar nicht das also old school ist new world tatsächlich in einem aspekt dass man mit anderen
spieler zusammen oder dass man angeregt wird mit anderen spieler zusammenzuspielen beziehungsweise
mit anderen spielern zu interagieren das ist ja das was ich auch schon lange bemängeln an
neuen mmo dass das dieser massive multiplayer teil bei mmo ist immer weniger wird du kannst
heute vom charakter erstellungs ding bis zum bis zum halbwegs brauchbaren endgame gear mehr
oder weniger solo solo machen mit quests und eventuell mal über den dungeon feiner irgendwo
rein hoppen rein hoppen gogogo buff gg eats next also das ist eines der punkte warum mir moderne
mmo ist nicht kein spaß machen da aus dem gesichtspunkt ist new world wirklich old school
du wirst angeregt mit mitspielern zu interagieren und das finde ich ist eine super geschichte
nicht gemeint ist sondern eher positiv also eine unglaublich dichte atmosphäre wie gesagt mich
erinnert insbesondere an die welten aus den piranier bei spielen und die sind ja für fans und da bin
ich einer von ich liebe ja risen zu tode und auch gothic ist ja insbesondere die diese atmosphärische
dicht und so weiter ein ganz ganz krasses ganz krasser das war die amc schild sozusagen von
daher da finde ich hat new world einen richtigen richtigen sog am start durch die welt nur dass
es halt ein mmo rpg ist es hat eine welt die man als m oder im kontext eines mmo rpg bereist das
ist was sehr neues das war noch nie da und ich habe sehr viele spieler gesehen jetzt in der beta
sehr viele andere kontent aber auch private spieler foren einträge kommentare und so weiter die
genau das jetzt realisiert was ich persönlich an der welt gerade in den startgebieten was mir
nicht so was mir persönlich jetzt nicht so gefallen hat war diese pirate wildwest angehauchten elemente
das ist einfach nicht mein setting aber man sieht ja es ist relativ abwechslungsreich also das könnte
auch sonst das könnte auch wie gesagt gerade das wenn du siehst bei nacht mit nebel und und
irgendwelche friedeskönner aus winter kommen im raum der beta und das auch sehr wertschätzen
und wie gesagt allein dadurch ist es hat das ding schon sehr eigenen stellenwert auch das
kampfsystem ist natürlich ein komplett eigenes also es gibt kein mmo rpg ich bekomme weniger
durch das jetzt deswegen müssen jetzt natürlich mehr leute subscriben logisch also any primus
gleich der stand halten kann noch keine ahnung übrigens dankeschön ich habe für den sub habe
ich gar nicht sind ribel und massive hier auch am stadtronachs und der puzzelmeister danke für
die selbst habe ich nicht mitbekommen war ich zu sehr am labern gild war zwei oder so sondern es
ist tatsächlich was komplett eigenes auch da fühlt sich das ganze so ein bisschen an wie
eine mischung aus dark souls aus risen oder gothic ok da soll ja gut da solls ist ja wirklich nur
das rollen eigentlich kleines bisschen witcher noch so drin oder das rollen und die endo aber
relativ klobig das auf jeden fall also es ist kein komplett durch optimiertes kampfsystem das ist
aber gut geschmeidig wäre aber ich finde es funktioniert trotzdem sehr sehr gut ja vor
allem als mmo rpg das kampfsystem ist wirklich nice man könnte sagen es hat vielleicht ein
bisschen wenig tiefe i excess dankeschön für den primes ab man könnte vielleicht sagen es hat ein
bisschen wenig tiefe ich meine du hast was zehn verschiedene waffen oder so und mini minimalste
skillbäume die skillbäume sind wirklich nicht sonderlich aus aus baufähig du hast da insgesamt
keine ahnung 4 5 styles drin und ein paar passive skills also es hält sich er hält sich wirklich
sehr in grenzen aber wie sich anfühlt so von hit feedback hit detection und und interaktivität
fand ich das kampfsystem echt cool eine sehr einzigartige erfahrung da sind wir noch mal bei
dem punkt zusammen mit der welt ist das nicht ähnlich zu so ich habe so nie gespielt außer
die beta so hatte den anschein ein bisschen eines eines interaktiven kampfsystems hat sich aber doch
du hast doch mehr die server tix im hintergrund gemerkt zumindest ich kann nur von der so beta
sprechen ja also du konntest des iso kampfsystem war zwar relativ interaktiv oder hat den anschein
gemacht von interaktiv aber wenn du beispielsweise da irgendwie einen sperr geworfen hast oder so
was das war glaube ich ein spell du hast schon noch gemerkt im hintergrund dass das immer noch den
nächsten server tick braucht für hits und sonst wie also ich finde new world hat von allen mmos die
ich bisher gespielt habe dass das den das der beste impact fühlen gefühl so im fight du hittest es
trifft aus hat das gefühl das trifft was passiert das wo es hingeht also das haben die wirklich gut
gemacht ist es einfach was neues ist es einfach so nicht der strukturellen oldschool haftigkeit
sozusagen gespielt der schöne ist auch dass viele was zum ersten mal subscrib du bist doch schon
ewig am start hier poggers durch das kampfsystem man so ein bisschen pvp ausprobieren konnten weil
es eben sehr viel intuitiver ist und man sehr viel ja destiny destiny würde ich nicht im gleichen
atemzug nennen destiny ist quasi ein halo mit rates da reinkommt als zum beispiel eben bei spielen
wie wow oder gilt war zwei oder so eben und es ist eben gleichzeitig auch sehr hart zu master so du
siehst sehr sehr schnell den unterschied zwischen einem guten und einem schlechten spieler ja von
daher also dass mir auch aufgefallen ich habe ein bisschen lauter pvp gemacht dass mir auch
aufgefallen also du musst da sehr gut abpassen wann wie skills down sind dass du erkennst was
da jetzt gejusst hat also ich glaube da kannst du wirklich ziemlich gut gegner outplayen wobei es
da auch wie in jedem mmo sicherlich massive op sachen geben wird die dich dann entweder
stun locken oder mit den passenden talenten one shotten oder was gibt es immer was man eigentlich
haben wollte das fand ich schön weil ich ja bin ja ein großer pvp aber ich kenne viele leute die
da gar nichts mit anfangen können kann ich auch nachvollziehen und new world ist eben auch so ein
spiel wo der ein oder andere sich da vielleicht mal reintraut weil eben das kampfsystem da wesentlich
intuitiver ist grafting war auch sehr sehr tief und sehr gut umgesetzt jetzt auch schon in der
betas auch so ein feedback was viele betas spieler das stimmt schon das stimmt leider ist es für mich
also dass grafting sieht mit nach dem durchdachtesten system im ganzen spiel aus aber ich muss halt sagen
ich mag grafting nicht deswegen waren auch diese ganzen zombie survival und und sonstige dinger
dies die letzten jahre übergeben hat er nicht mein fall ich bin kein crafter in mmos ist einfach
so ich mochte grafting noch nie in keinem mmo ich habe in keinem mmo was ich gespielt habe je
groß gecraftet mag grafting mich ist halt mein problem jetzt ja das heißt nicht dass es grafting
schlecht gemacht ist ich bin kein crafter in mmos angebracht haben das ist auch sehr schön
verzahnt ich teorie kraft übelst gerne weil so wie du sie erfahren sollst und gucken ob man
irgendwelche encounter austricksen kann oder irgendwas sonstige dinger machen kann mit pets
irgendwelche gegner raus pullen und komische dinger machen aber ich kräfte nicht gerne das
übrigens auch der grund warum es sehr gut ist dass es keine mounds gibt das war auch so ein
thema das kam immer wieder als auch in den vielen vielen streams über gemacht haben in der beta
und so eine forderung die die häufiger haben für die habe ich euch habe ich euch eigentlich
erzählt dass ich mal fast gebannt wäre wegen klitsch geklitten fast muss man jetzt dazu
sein fast gebannt worden wäre weil ich in daug geklitscht habe wo mir aber nicht bewusst war
dass das illegal ist habe ich glaube ich nie erzählt es gab einen encounter in daug da
konntest du also normalerweise muss war unter wasser du musstest du musstest runter tauchen du
brauchst also quasi auch tauch tauch dinger ich guck mal ob ich ich guck mal ob ich das noch
finde jetzt kommt boomer story da müsste jetzt durch weiß nicht ob man den encounter irgendwo
sieht da auch grafik ist halt im jahr 2000 irgendwas man sieht man sieht keine encounter
hier gibt es keine screenshots von ja egal zumindest man musste runter tauchen und dann
war das quasi so eine so eine so eine horde modus unter wasser du musstest also du musstest
quasi auch ohne also dein drank liefern dann auch mit der zeit ab du musstest quasi wellen von
gegnern killen und die wurden richtig schwer mit der zeit und du durftest das gebiet nicht
verlassen so und was ich damals gemacht habe ist da war glaube ich der friseur auch auch richtig
hart am start mit mit farmen ich hatte damals eine klasse die hatten ein pet ein pet was man
steuern kann also hatte man so ein control window konnte man sein pet hinschicken so und man konnte
es damals schon hart klitschen indem man sein pet gebufft hat mit allen buffs dies gab buffs
war muss man sagen buffs auf pets waren in daug ziemlich verbackt das was buffs auf pets gemacht
haben ist nicht wirklich die statistik des pets zu steigern sondern absorb zu steigern also sprich
du konntest einen pet in buffen und dex buffen und stärke buffen und es hat dadurch mehr
ausgehalten das war total verbackt so und wir haben uns einfach buffer hingestellt aus außerhalb der
gruppe die haben ein pet gebufft ich habe das pet reingeschickt reingeschickt gegner sind gesporned
und dann zu mir zurückgeholt und dann gab es einen bug bei dem encounter wenn das pet aus dem aus
dem encounter radius rausgelaufen ist dann sind die mobs die man killen musste nicht mehr zum
spawn zurück das heißt man konnte die gegner killen von außerhalb ohne dass sie dich angreifen
konnten und das haben wir bestimmt in einer woche wir haben gekämpft davor leute wir hatten leute
die haben sich in wecker gestellt wenn respawn war das so das war die richtig krasse lmo zeit
ja und wir haben das ding so hart abgekämmt wir haben das in einer woche bestimmt 20-25 mal
gefarmt und das war übelst viel wert das ding damals weil es uns schwieriger schwieriger
encounter war den du auch nicht irgendwie mit ein paar leuten machen konntest wo du eigentlich
normalerweise zwei richtig gut ausgerüstete gruppen hatte zwei gruppen in daug waren 16 leute und wir
haben das halt so hart geklitscht und irgendwann haben sie halt gesagt ok wir fixen jetzt den bug
mit den pets mit dem pet oder also bei diesem encounter und sie haben rausbekommen also in
auf dem englischen server muss ja sagen deutsch und englisch selber unterschiedliche betreiber und
die haben damals gesagt hey wer bugs abused hat kann sich bei uns melden und wer sich meldet der
verliert zwar die artefakte die getroppt worden aber es gibt keine weiteren konsequenzen und wer
sich nicht meldet wird keine ahnung kriegt kriegt banz so was haben wir gemacht wir haben uns
natürlich nicht gemeldet als es dann auf dem deutschen server kam wir haben uns natürlich
nicht gemeldet weil wir uns gedacht haben der deutsche betreiber ist viel zu dumm der hat
doch garantiert keine locks mehr davon dass wir vor fünf wochen was gefahmt haben natürlich so
deutscher betreiber macht das ganze sagt ihr könnt euch bei uns melden ihr könnt euch bei uns melden
wer wer das abused hat diesen bug wir haben uns nicht gemeldet und ich habe echt da gesich
habe jeden tag meine country frecht ob ich keinen bann gekriegt haben und wir haben kein bann
bekommen wir haben richtig gelegen die konnten es nicht nachvollziehen wer da vor fünf wochen
mal irgendwann was gefahmt hat nichts gebannt nichts easy money easy life ich habe mir von dem ich
habe ich habe mir von dem von dem money was ich also nicht echt geld sondern sondern in game money was
mir für die artefakte damals gekauft habe ich hatte glaube ich das beste query template wirklich
auf dem kompletten server oder eines der besten eu das ding war unglaublich teuer aber ich habe
halt krass klitsch gefahmt krasse mmo boomer stories ich weiß als old school keine menschen
heute kennt aber ja das das war meine ich kann sagen meine jugend ja mmo farben 360 kreisel
kreiten absolut kein verständnis hat muss ich ganz klar sagen was vor was hat er kein verständnis
so ein thema das kam immer wieder als auch in den vielen vielen streams über gemacht haben in
abt angebracht haben das ist auch sehr schön verzahnt ist mit der kraft im system in der
art und weise wie du sie erfahren sollst und das ist übrigens auch der grund warum es sehr gut
ist dass es keine mounds gibt das war auch so ein thema ja wieder jetzt auf den streams über
gemacht haben in abt und so eine so eine forderung die die häufiger mal auf kam für die ich
absolut kein verständnis hat muss ich ganz klar sagen weil natürlich kann ich verstehen dass
leute vielleicht nicht so gerne laufen wollen wobei dann vielleicht tatsächlich nie war doch das
falsche spiel für sie ist ja ich kann ich kann es nachvollziehen aber das problem ist halt man muss
halt mounds nicht nur als mounds begreifen wenn man sie denn ins ins spiel reinbringt sondern mit
all ihren konsequenzen ja ja vollkommen richtig deswegen finde ich flug mounds in mmos prinzipiell
immer problematisch ist ja jetzt schon nicht riesig die ist auf jeden fall groß genug finde ich aber
die ist jetzt nicht gigantisch und wenn mounds im spiel wären dann wäre die plötzlich winzig
dann würden würde würde uns das ist kein problem ja ja ich da gebe ich da gebe ich da gebe ich im
follow ganz rechts recht fortbewegung muss muss zu den maps passen muss zu dem game passen das
problem bei new world ist warum die leute sich mounds wünschen weil der einzige die einzige
möglichkeit zu leveln ist kreisel quest grind langweilig erst fack kreisel quest
krein natürlich wünschen sich leute mounds dafür später später kannst du später kannst du ab
glaube ich 28 oder so geht das los kannst du den ersten dungeon farm und auch diese diese rift
daf haben dann sieht das ein bisschen anders aus da machst du dann rift grind und sowas aber
gerade aus dem gesicht man kann nicht verstehen dass viele leute viele leute nach mounds geschrien
haben das problem hatst du in wo weniger da hast du halt da hast du zwar auch quest gemacht aber du
hast dann später auch in mounds gekriegt und ist die konntest die wege schneller zurück klingen
oder in noch oldschooligeren mmos nehmen wir mal wieder dark als beispiel da hast du gar nicht
durch quests gelevelt leute soll ich euch mal was sagen wisst ihr wie man in dark gelevelt hat man
hat eine gruppe gemacht mit anderen spielern und hat zusammen gespielt und monster gekillt das ist
ja in der heutigen zeit fast undenkbar dass man mit anderen spielern zusammen level musste du bist
an einen spot hast geguckt haben die platz hast gefragt habt was weiß ich brauchte in eurer gruppe
noch xy dann bist du dahin gelaufen die haben dich in weitet und du hast mit anderen spielern
acht stunden am stück eintönigste mob crime action gemacht aber daraus sind ich sage es
euch wie es ist es sind in mmos freundschaft fürs leben entstanden durch solche durch solche
geschichten weil wir einfach nur auf mounds da durchreiten würden es wäre fürs ressourcen
sammeln fürs gathering von von eben crafting material wäre es furchtbar weil es ja nicht
bei wo ist wo du alle 500 meter mal irgendwie ein erz oder sowas oder eine friedensblume sondern du
kannst ja keine keine 50 cm laufen ohne das nächste das nächste objekt zu finden was du
eben mitnehmen kannst das wäre grausam fürs crafting meiner meinung nach es wäre auch furchtbar
wenn du einfach durch die welt reitest und diesen diesen tollen entdecker trieb mir gerade wenn
irgendwie paar hunderte meter durch durch ich mag auch keine anderen menschen aber in mmos habe
ich da keine probleme mit weil das ja ziel gerichtet ist ich habe in mmos immer anfälle
gekriegt da kann der fabian ein lied von singen er hat das gleiche problem gehabt wenn es nicht wenn
es nicht voran ging also wenn die leute rum genubt haben in den gruppen das ging mir immer auf den
sack ja wenn ich dann wenn ich dann irgendwelchen cast dann erklären musste was ihre spells machen
und sowas oder leute ich bin mal kurz afk und ist eine halbe stunde steht da steht da rum und
pull laufen irgendwelche mobs weil er im response steht also was da habe ich immer anfälle gekriegt ich war richtig kleiner kackflamer damals muss man muss man sagen also ich war wahrscheinlich
konnte mich die meisten leute nicht ab also gerade wenn es um optimisation in den spielen ging da war
ich echt richtig richtig toxic as fuck irgendwie eine richtig geile blume die du nie gesehen hast
ein richtig geiles erz oder so will immer noch kackflamer ein bisschen ad absurdum geführt durch
mounds und es wäre natürlich auch eine katastrophe fürs open world pvp ja ja du hast recht nur der
unterschied ist also wo classic gebe ich dir gebe ich dir sofort sofort recht und auch später ab
dungeon finder ist vorbei weil ab dungeon finder kannst du dich aufführen wie die ax dem walde
und du wirst die leute nie wiedersehen und wie gesagt es hätte auch noch andere konsequenzen
hätte auf fast alle spiel aspekte hätte es oder für fast alle spielaspekte hätte es konsequenzen
in der regel negative das heißt die entscheidung dass keine mounds drin sind ist die einzig vernünftige
und richtige die man die man haben kann ich kann es nachvollziehen was er sagt ja leuchtet ein es geht
darum wie die mounds auf die anderen spielaspekte ausstrahlen würden wie sie diese beeinflussen
an der recht es gibt so viele leute die da keine sekunde darüber nachdenken die mounds fordern
ohne sich zu vergegenwärtigen was es eben mitbringen würde von daher das wollte ich an der
stelle dass er wohl schon die ein oder anderen immer wo es gespielt hat also er spricht da aus
erfahrung würde ich sagen könnte man kutschen system von stadt zu stadt nachdenken um ein
bisschen weniger laufzeit sozusagen zu haben das wäre eine gute möglichkeit weil es keine negativen
konsequenzen hätte wie eben die mounds das könnte ich mir auf jeden fall gut vorstellen aber wie
gesagt dass das noch mal zu dem thema denn die frage kam eben sehr viel aus die beta war aber auch
geprägt wirklich von sehr schönen momenten die wahrscheinlich auch mit mounds so nicht möglich
gewesen wären es gab zum beispiel so ein moment da war ich mit den das war relativ zu beginn noch
also ich habe die hardcore gespielt ich habe das ich habe das auch nebenbei gespielt aber zu
damaliges hat war da auch mal mein mmo und ich habe mit dem friseur zusammen wir haben ja mehr
oder weniger alle neu erscheinen mmos ausprobiert jahrelang aber da ist nie wieder was rangekommen
also gebiete die noch neutral waren die noch keine seite keine fraktion für sich genommen
hatte da gab es einen moment da bin ich mit den bonjour leuten zuerst nach week water und
danach eben scale aufgebrochen zu einer zeit in der wir eben auch sehr andere level waren also
waren alle noch nicht bereit in diese gebiete eigentlich zu gehen aber wir wollten halt die
städte claim also wollten die städte einnehmen für uns beanspruchen deshalb sind wir heute das ist
das was mmos ausmacht was man hier sieht das ist die das ist dieser massively multiplayer
aspekt mit anderen leuten zusammen in einer virtuellen welt was cooles machen das ist das
was mmos ausmacht kein anonymer dungeon finder crying kein solo gequest den ganzen tag so was
das ist das was mmos ausmacht haben uns also als riesiger pulk quasi dahin durchgeschoben
und durchgestorben sind wir das war echt ein geiles abenteuer so dass das ist schön sowas
mal zu erleben weil es eben wie gesagt auch keine mit skalierenden gebiete sind sondern es ist eben
sehr schnell möglich mein gebiet zu zu rennen das deutlich deutlich zu schwer ist für dich und dann
muss eben so eine so eine so eine so eine massenbewegung daraus machen und offen dass die
leute irgendwie durchkommen zwar auf jeden fall cooles abenteuer hat sehr viel spaß gemacht und
hat wie gesagt dann dazu geführt dass bond war ein recorder hatte und wir hatten abends gel auch
relativ lang das war das war sehr sehr schön sind zwei sehr schöne coole gebiete das eine so ein
piratiges nest das andere so ein asiatisch angehauchter ort sehr sehr schön was das eigentlich
für exquisite musik ist das da soll es nie was weiß einer was das für eine für eine musik im
hintergrund ist soziale erfahrung also ich erinnere mich an die namen von den leuten aus meiner
community mit denen ich zusammen gespielt habe auch aus anderen communities mit denen ich dann
mal expeditionen gelaufen bin spontan oder so corrupted breaches geschlossen habe pvp gemacht
habe und so weiter und das sind alles momente die viele oder fast alle der modernen mmo eben leider
nicht mehr bieten können weil sie sich der größten spielergruppe angeschlossen haben oder an an an
biedern muss man fast schon sagen die es eben gibt und das sind die gelegenheitsspieler und die
solo spieler hier jetzt nicht darum das heißt ja immer wieder in videos auch in dem video zuletzt
habe ich das gesagt es geht nicht darum dass eine mmo spieler besser ist als die andere oder dass
man irgendwie nicht selber auch mal wenn man jetzt noch hardcore mmo spieler ist so wie ich dann auch
gerne mal in paar jahren vielleicht selber mein die in die gelegenheitsspielergruppe rutschen könnte
wer weiß wer weiß das schon da würde ich so also ich bin mittlerweile auch eindeutig eher
vergleich zu früher der gelegenheitsspielergruppe zuzuordnen wenn es um die häufigkeit geht wie
oft ich spiele was aber auch auf was irgendwie daran liegt dass ich teilweise viele games gar
nicht mehr begeistern aber ich bekomme so manche sachen nicht raus wenn ich mmos spiele
dann will ich dann will ich das game irgendwie auch verstehen durchschauen und ich krieg anfälle
wenn irgendwas unoptimiert ist das kann ich ganz ganz schwierig erklären also mich nervt das mich
nervt das ultra ab ich weiß also das letzte mmo was wir länger gespielt haben zusammen mit dem
friseur weiß noch war final fantasy 14 also ich habe immer echt anfälle bekommen du musstest
ja da so daily daily missions machen für für xp und und und wäre und sowas ich habe immer anfälle
bekommen wenn du leute hast die ihre spells nicht kennen und sowas ich habe ja keine probleme damit
wenn das wenn es ein einsteiger dungeon ist aber wenn es irgendwas höher level ist höher level
liegeres ist wenn wenn dann irgendwie heiler nicht wissen dass sie neben dem primary heal noch
einen schild haben oder sowas kriege ich immer anfälle ich sage ich war früher toxic as fuck in
mmos und ich krieg manche sachen krieg ich einfach nicht raus wenn ich wenn ich so total planloses
unoptimieres rum gehampelt sie krieg ich anfalle beide bei null auf das video bezogen jetzt na
nur nur nur auf das video bezogen das ist das ist so was das krieg ich das krieg ich obwohl
ich casual spieler bin krieg ich das wahrscheinlich nie raus ihres rum geeiere würde ich da eher von
abraten ehrlich gesagt aber alle großen modernen mmos sind auf diesen spieler typen
ausgelegt als eben die größte gruppe das alles finde ich auch nicht so lohnen gelegenheit spieler
und ich will es für mich nicht mal wieder ein mmo das soziale spieler belohnt das viel spieler
belohnt und das was ich auch gut finde oder dass einfach das anspruchsvollen level content bietet
so und das das feier ich wirklich sehr ohne dass man nicht zu bieten hat für die für die
gelegenheit spieler aber es hat schon deutlich finde ich immer noch in seinem kern ein fokus auf
mir auf wie gesagt auf die auf die sozialen spieler auf die viele spieler es mag anspruchsvollen
level content und so weiter das finde ich sehr sehr sehr sehr schön die grundsätzliche resonanz
so beton soweit ich das mitbekommen habe war eben wie gesagt eine sehr sehr positive es gab
aber einige mäkel und auch eine große sorge die ich auch teile nämlich dass es hinten raus für
pve spieler gerade also gerade für pv spieler gerade vielleicht sogar für gelegenheit spieler die
vielleicht auch von gibt nichts oder feine fantasy also von so einem klassischen theme park
im himmel dass es da an content dünn werden könnte massiv musik im hintergrund denn wie gesagt das ist
die pvp la die sind wahrscheinlich schon glücklich mit dem permanenten mit der politik mit diesen
permanenten territorialen kriegen das ist die frage das soll die frage wie viel abwechslung
tiefe das bietet pvp ist erstmal unglaublich motivierend wenn es halbwegs gut umgesetzt ist
weil spaß macht es ein bisschen bisschen adrenalin noch dabei in den ersten pvp schlachten aber wenn
du immer die gleichen zwei scenarien spielst ist das auch fucking langweilig dass das also mal
gucken mal gucken uns haben da haben darüber hinaus ja auch noch was auf dem world pvp wo
man mit den forsten eine wundervolle mechanik reingebracht hat um das aktiv zu halten spannend
zu halten dann hast du den outpost rush modus noch oben drauf das heißt du hast das crafting
natürlich was für jeden spielertypen eigentlich relevant ist ja das war ja nicht brauchen mehr
futter so was wie zum beispiel neue waffen da wurde auch viel darüber diskutiert was kommt
eigentlich in der nächsten zeit aber gerade die pvp gerade diejenigen die vielleicht nur die
invasions mitnehmen die die expedition also die dungeons mitnehmen für die glaube ich könnte es
hinten raus ja knapp werden da muss das spiel in den nächsten zwölf monaten auf jeden fall beweisen
dass da mehr kommt denn wie gesagt aber es ist amazon für die er solo gelegenheitsspieler für
die glaube ich hat das spiel derzeit noch am wenigsten zu bieten das heißt da wurde auf jeden
fall auch deutlich wo das fleisch auf den rippen sozusagen noch am dünnsten ist das ist ein schöner
spruch den muss ich mir merken wo das fleisch auf den rippen noch am dünnsten ist das finde ich gut
tangiert das jetzt nicht so weil ich weiß genau was ich von dem spiel haben will und das bietet
es jetzt schon für mich ich freue mich natürlich auch über jede neue waffe die rauskommt und so
weiter denn jedes mal wenn eine neue waffe rauskommt ist man wieder hat man wieder lust
nur das mal auszuprobieren aus zu testen und so oder wenn man neue dungeon kommt aber gerade
die pve spieler für die muss mehr kommen auch das hat die beta gezeigt was natürlich auch ein
großes problem war war die server stabilität die war gerade in den ersten jahren fast ruf ich
konnte meinen ersten stream ist auch normal so normal mmo release über vier stunden ich habe
keine einzige sekunde gespielt war die ganze zeit nur in erwartestange das war so sehr egal es
wird dann besser mit der zeit aber es gab eben bis zuletzt noch bugs verheerende bugs regelrecht
es gab zum beispiel ich hatte permanent so und so hast du mal wieder pwe reingeschaut nein ich
habe nur gehört dass es den patch gab zur letzten zur letzten season der nicht gut angekommen ist
den alle geflamed haben und dass act 1 jetzt sogar schwer sein soll wo ich weil ich glaube
mittlerweile dass es an einem ring lag der dazu geführt hat dass ich nicht 100 ausdauer sondern
108 ausdauer hatte und das hat dazu geführt dass ich oftmals nach ein paar ausweichrollen dann
plötzlich so ein so eine art die buff hatte dass ich permanent erschöpft war und keine ausweich
rolle mehr machen konnte und nicht springen und wenn du das ist schlecht und in waffen spielst
und spielziel spielst der sehr darauf ausgelegt ist dass die mobility hat nicht so geil wenn
du das hast von daher das hat mich sehr ein new world oder ja new world hat evga grafikkarten
frittiert aber nicht new world sondern der hersteller hat kacke gebaut du kannst nicht
mit einem spiel eine grafikkarte kaputt machen wenn du die ganz normalen schrittstellen verwendest
die dafür da sind die grafikkarten waren kacke und new world ist halt in zur falschen zeit am
falschen ort gewesen die hatten das problem dass sie die fps nicht limitiert haben im launcher und
die leute lange im launcher gehockt haben weil server so voll waren das kann dir theoretisch
mit jedem x beliebigen anderen programm auch passieren new world haben halt viele gespielt
war halt zur falschen zeit am falschen ort der fehler liegt aber eindeutig bei den herstellern
der hardware und nicht bei new world auch bis zuletzt noch probleme mit der teleportation mit
der schnellreise das hatte ich zu beginn auch das hat sich dann irgendwann gebessert und es gab
noch ein paar andere technische fehler also von daher da hat man natürlich noch mal gesehen dass
das spiel da deswegen verschieben es jetzt ja auch viel fehler korrektur also die haben gesagt sie
verschieben es jetzt noch mal glauben monat oder so was ich auch gut finde besser als unfertigen
gram zu release ich meine natürlich wird sich da grundlegend nichts dran ändern wenn man jetzt
das gameplay scheiße fand da findet man das gameplay bei release auch scheiße aber zumindest die
fehler die jetzt erst unter last aufgefallen sind in der beta da kann man ja versuchen daran zu
arbeiten und ich habe wirklich den eindruck dass amazon versucht da was rauszuhauen was von
technischer seite so polischt wie geht es ist halt die frage ob inhaltlich überzeugt gelingt
neben den technischen fehlern war natürlich dann auch die warteschlange gerade zu beginn
riesenproblem zwar natürlich absehbar bei so vielen streamern plus deren communities
hat aber bei meiner gilde zum beispiel dazu geführt dass sich nach ungefähr der hälfte
der zeit die leute gesplittet haben in leute die auf dem server geblieben sind und weiter mit
mir gespielt haben und andere die gemeinsam lieber auf einem chilligeren aber neu gestartet haben um
überhaupt mal vernünftig spielen zu können auch zusammen spielen zu können das verstehe ich
absolut so kleine freue ich mich freut er mich da supportet hat aber ich kann total nachvollziehen
dass es da leute gab die sagten so dieses spiel ist geil und wir würden gerne mehr spielen aber wir
wollen halt auch spielen können von daher kann ich total nachvollziehen dass sich da ein paar leute
dann einen eigenen server gesucht haben das wird natürlich dann hoffentlich zum release oder mit
sicherheit zum release wird es ganz anders aussehen da werden wir natürlich alle gemeinsam in
einer kompanie durchstarten wahrscheinlich sogar in zwei kompanien einer vielspieler kompanie also
kompanie ist gilde und einer für diejenigen die ein bisschen unregelmäßiger spielen aber eben auch
dabei sein wollen denn das ist so das schöne bei new world jeder kann einen wertvollen beitrag
leisten und ein wertvolles teil sein der hat plan sollte ich new world zu release spielen
gehe ich bei dem in die gilde easy will entweder indem man gold oder das hat schon hand und
fußwasser sagt oder ressourcen dass die dass die deutschen streamer da nix gerissen haben
wundern mich nicht wenn ich mir egal ich bin warum sollte die leute jetzt flame aber hätten sie
mehr wie ihn gehabt da hätten wir garantiert bessere chancen gehabt sammelt oder pvp mission mit macht
oder was heißt wir ich habe nicht auf dem server gespielt jeder kann sich und das ist wirklich
finde ich ein sehr schöner aspekt im rahmen seiner möglichkeiten einbringen und irgendwie wertvoll
sein so lange halbwegs regelmäßig spielte wer nicht regelmäßig spielt der fliegt natürlich
wie das immer ist dann irgendwann aus einer gilde raus aber da ist letzten endes eigentlich für
jeden platz für die sucht die kompanie also für die main kompanie würde es zudem immer ein wöchentliches
großes projekt geben das habe ich auch schon in den streams geteilt also zum beispiel den
angriff auf ein gebiet auf eine stadt und da wird dann eben kollektiv dran gearbeitet das geht dann
so lang das geht dann so lang bis der ein dem anderen mal was weglutet dann ist großes gillendrama
angesagt wer kennt es nicht nein ich bin dran nein ich bin dran nein was jetzt hier oder mit
gefleimt da geht es zur sache von daher also da wird es auch immer bei lud hört da spaß
auf hier geben das dann gemeinsam oder gemeinsam die kräfte für gebündelt werden da die frage
immer wieder aufkommt auf welchem server starten wir das kann ich leider noch nicht sagen wir haben
noch keine offizielle serverliste zum release ich werde aber das und andere details noch über den
discord kommunizieren es wird übrigens die fraktion miradas also die marodeure die grünen
also es geht nicht mehr anders da bin ich vollkommen gebrandet ich hoffe wir dürfen das dann auch nicht
deutsch aussprechen marodeure sozusagen ich habe auch das das t-shirt bekommen und diese diese
flagge und so und ich kann nichts anderes mehr spielen also es wird auf jeden fall marodeure
wie gesagt alles andere organisatorische läuft dann über den discord und am strich würde ich
sagen die close beta von die world war ein großer erfolgt immer ziemlich gut gefallen mängel die
zahlreich waren und anderer probleme konnten sich viele leute ein bild von den stärken von
new world machen auch von den schwächen wie gesagt größte baustelle definitiv der pve endgame
konnte man ganz klar sagen dass die entwickler haben ich auch mal im video gesagt sammeln haben
jetzt ein sehr groß und das habe ich nach zwölf läffeln gesagt anscheinend ist ja da auch was
dran denn wie gesagt gerade technisch muss das wesentlich besser laufen der release als die
close beta bleibt also zu hoffen dass man die erfahrungen und anregungen aus der community
daneben zeitnah umsetzen kann und werden hoffentlich halbwegs reibungslosen release
am 31 august bekommen sofern das möglich ist so gilt dann fragen sind immer cringe
entschätzt lässt euch das mal durch die deutsche kompanie extremes sucht aktive mitspieler 18 plus
um gemeinsam strukturiert zu rocken erfahren oder nicht jeder ist willkommen wir haben einen plan
ok es geht ich habe schon klinische gelten an an den announcements gesehen aber die sind
teilweise schon ein bisschen bisschen wie gesagt zehn minuten video auf dem hauptkanal kommen da
gerne reinschauen und ja ansonsten wird auf dem twitch kanal da unbedingt vorbei schauen unbedingt
folgen uns da dabei sein wird im august noch ein anderes programm geben da werden wir die
wartezeit sozusagen mit diversen betas teilweise open betas oder spiel neun spiele releases werden
wir da gut rum kriegen würde mich also freuen wenn ich euch da sehe so viel erstmal zu beta ich
hatte sehr viel spaß ich mag new world unglaublich gerne und freue mich da mega auf den release
von daher freut mich oder würde mich freuen euch da zu sehen würde mich bei ihm merkt man
er hat schon eine andere mmo gespielt weiß wovon er spricht doch gerade schon alles war meins ich
speichere mir das mal kurz alles bookmark all tabs achter achter zack leute ich muss
jetzt unbedingt was futtern ich habe hunger wie sau wir sehen uns bis denn macht's gut
vier stunden alter heute was hier los massiv aufwachen stream bis denn wir sehen uns zu